What's up code squad. My name is Kyla gang.
And today in this video I prepared 12 beginner
Python projects. And I'm going to walk you guys
through the implementations for all of them. Now,
a couple of notes before we begin, here's a
list of all the projects. These projects are in
order from what I consider to be the easiest,
most beginner friendly to the most complex.
They'll range from madlibs, which is a string
concatenation to an unbeatable, tic tac toe AI
to photo editing in Python. In addition, you might
see me make a few mistakes run into a few bugs
during these tutorials. The reason why I decided
to leave these in there is because I think it's a
very important skill to know how to go back and
fix your mistakes. Because everybody inevitably
makes mistakes. And I thought it would be
really good for you guys to see some of my logic
when I go back, and I fix them. And of
course, if you guys are interested in more,
be sure to subscribe to my YouTube channel, Kylie
Yang for coding projects, and just fun computer
science related topics. Follow me on Twitch Kyle
Yang for live streams of unedited coding sessions
and follow me on instagram and twitter at
Kylie Whiting. Okay, so let's get started.
In a traditional Madlib, you would have a bunch of
blanks in a paragraph. And you would have somebody
fill out those blanks and then read the paragraph
out loud with the words that they chose in those
blanks. So we're going to recreate this project
in Python using string concatenation. So let's
talk a little bit about string concatenation.
In other words, how do you put strings together.
So suppose we want to create a string that says
subscribe to blank, and this blank is going
to be a YouTuber. So we can create a variable
YouTuber, and this is going to be some string.
So there are a few ways to create the
string that says subscribe to the YouTuber.
One way to do it is we can have the string
subscribe to, and then we can concatenate it
with youtuber by just adding a plus sign. The
second way is to have a string subscribe to
and then have these curly braces. And what we
can do is we can call string dot format YouTuber,
and what this is going to do, it's going to put
the YouTuber, whatever the value of youtuber is
into where the curly braces are in that string.
And now the third method, and what I think is the
most straightforward is called an F string. And
an F string, we can define this f string by just
prepending an F in front of the string. And then
we can say subscribe to and then the curly braces.
And then directly in the curly braces, we can
add the variable name YouTuber. So with an
empty string, let's try running this real fast
just to check that there are like no errors,
and they all turn out to be the same thing.
So let's open terminal and run the script.
So here we see subscribe to blank, three times.
No errors. Okay, everything looks good. So now
let's try with the YouTuber actually filled
out to some string. Let's just try Kylie Yang.
So let's run this again. And you'll see that
now all three of these print statements,
say subscribe to Kylie Yang. And so for the
sake of this Madlib, we're going to use the
last one the F string just because I think that's
the cleanest way to express string concatenation.
Okay, so starting this Madlib. So first we're just
going to assign Madlib variable equals and then an
F string. So let's say computer programming
is so blank or blank is some adjective. And
now we have to define this variable adjective.
So we can say adjective equals input. So here,
we're going to get a user input.
And let's do adjective as a prompt.
It makes me so excited all the time. Because
I love to blank. Let's make that a verb.
And this break right here, this is just saying,
This is telling Python Hey, this string has gone
on to the next line. That's all that little
slash there is. Stay hydrated and verb to
like you are and let's make this a famous person.
exclamation mark. Okay, so let's just use that
example right there. And now Don't forget to
define these variables verb one verb two and
famous person. So up here we're gonna say verb one
equals input. And the prompt is just going to be
verb because all we want is a user to input some
verb. And now verb two is going to be the same.
thing, but instead verb to will be the name of
the variable. And then famous person, again equals
input. So we're getting user input. And we're
gonna say famous person as a prompt. Okay, so I
actually have to remove the space. And then at the
end, we have to print the Madlib to show the user.
So that's it though. Now we can run this
code. Alright, so adjective let's do amazing
verb. How about skydive, and then
another verb jump, and a famous person?
Captain America Okay, so our Madlib is computer
programming is so amazing. It makes me so excited
all the time. Because I love to skydive, stay
hydrated and jump like you are Captain America.
And so yeah, there you have it. That's Madlib in
Python. Alright, so if you guys actually download
my code, which is linked somewhere below, you'll
notice that there's a file called random Mad
libs.py. What this is going to do is it'll choose
one of these four madlibs that I prepared, and
it'll let you play that game. Alright, adjective
pretty, another adjective soft, another adjective.
Pretty glow bursts suddenly, across the
enchanted sky above them as an edge of
dazzling sun appeared over the sill of the
nearest mass, the light hit both of their hand
at the same time. So that Voldemort's was suddenly
a flaming water bottle. What did I just
read? Anyways, there's a Madlib for you.
First, I'm going to teach you guys how
to implement a guessing game where the
computer has a secret number. And we are trying
to guess that secret number. So the first step
is actually having the computer generate a secret
number for us to guess. And in order to do that,
we're going to import random. Whenever we
call import random, it actually goes to this
package that comes with Python. And it says,
Hey, all of these functions that are here,
like make these accessible in our scripts,
so that we can call these functions.
So for example, in order to get a random number,
something like random dot Rand int might be very
applicable because it returns a random integer n,
such that A is less than or equal to n less than
or equal to b. So a and b are the parameters of
this function. And we need to pass in arguments.
I'm going to define a function and I'm going
to define this function. Let's say, guess,
I'm going to make x a parameter so that we can
pass that into this random get number function.
So first, we need to get the random number.
And our random number. Well, we're going to use
random dot and then Rand int, which is exactly
what we saw down here. Let's make it between one
and x. Okay, so now, basically, what this is going
to return is a random number for us to guess.
Okay, what's our second step here? Our second step
is, once the computer has a random number, we
need to guess right, we need to guess in Terminal
and input what our guess of the number is, and
the computer will tell us whether it's too high,
too low. Or if we've guessed the number
correctly, I need to keep looping until
I get the right answer, right. So that sounds
like a job for loops. And basically, since we
don't have a predefined universe to iterate over,
we're going to use a while loop. So let's insert
while in there. And now in this while
loop, we need an expression here, right?
And now for this expression, when do we want to
stop this loop, we want to stop it when our guests
number equals the random number. So that means our
expression should be something along the lines of
guess does not equal random number, then we
want to iterate over some things. Now we need
to actually define this guest. And we're not going
to make a guess up here because we're just trying
to initialize the variable tell Python that this
variable exists. So we can go back and change it
later. So after a random number, I'm going to
say guests equals zero, right? Because we don't
want our guests to ever accidentally equal that
random number. and here if guess is zero, well,
random numbers random dot Rand int between one
and x. And that means that it will never be zero.
So while the guests tonight equal the random
number, we're going to get the users guests. So
guests equals input guests a number and we can
even get little fancier here, between one. And
so let's use an F string. And we can do x. Let's
just see what that looks like real fast. Let's
call our function guests at the bottom of our
script. And then let's just print our guests.
Let's see what happened when we run this. Alright,
so if we run this, pick guess a number between one
and 10. Let's do five. Okay, so we've printed the
number, right? And I'm just going to cast this as
integer because I want my guesses to be integers.
So what do we have? so far? The computer has said,
okay, I've gotten a random number. And now we've
set up this loop where I can keep guessing until I
guess, the right number. But that's no fun, right?
We kind of want the computer to give us some
feedback, give us some clues into what's right
and what's wrong. So that means that I'm going
to use some if statements and these statements
are going to tell me Hey, you're kind of high,
kind of low, or, oh, maybe you've gotten it.
Alright, so let's add these if statements in
so if our guests is less than our random number,
then we can print. Sorry, guests again, too low.
All right, but then elsif, our guests is greater
than our random number, then we can print
sorry, guests again, too high. And then if it's
not less than if it's greater than that means it's
just right. It's in that Goldilocks zone, right?
And that means that you have guessed the jackpot,
you have guessed that random number. And so
what do we do that? Well, we actually don't
have to do anything. Because remember this loop.
While the guest does not equal the random number,
it does all of this. But as soon as your guest
equals a random number. So once you've input this
guest, we don't hit any of these if statements.
So then we come back to while the guests is not
equal to number, but now your guests equals
the random number. So it actually breaks out
of this loop. Meaning that at the very end, I can
print. Yay, congrats. You have guessed the number.
And you know what we can even just
tossing a random number in there.
So let's use our F string again. Yay, congrats.
You have guessed the number random number
correctly. Alright, are we ready
to play? So if we go to terminal?
Let's run our script. Okay, it gets a number
between one and 10. I'm going to do four.
Okay, it was too high. So maybe two to low.
Alright, so that means if four is too high, if two
is too low, it has to be three, right? Wow, look
at that. I've guessed the number three correctly.
Alright, so we talked about earlier how the
computer is guessing our number. But we can
also do the complete inverse of that function, we
can come up with a secret number and we can have
the computer try to guess it. So now I'm going
to create a new function called computer guests.
effects. Great, right. And in this function,
let's think about what we actually have to do.
So I have a secret number. And I'm not going to
tell the computer what the secret number is right?
That basically means the computer has a range of
numbers to work with a minimum and a maximum a
low and a high. Okay, so that means let's set the
low and the high initially because we know what
that is without even having to loop over anything.
So I'm going to say low, the lower bound is one,
and the high is x. Because we do have that entire
range between one and x to work with initially
until the user can provide some feedback, we
need to be able to tell the computer if it's too
high or too low, or if they've guessed correctly,
which means that let's initialize a feedback
variable. Alright, feedback. And at first, there
aren't any guesses, nothing's too high, nothing's
too low. So just like how we initialize guests to
be zero, let's initialize this to an empty string.
And now basically, we want to loop over
this feedback expression. So while this
feedback expression does not equal what we're
going to make it represent when it's correct,
let's do c because C for correct. So
while this feedback does not equal C,
Well, the first thing I need the computer to do is
to get a new number. So I'm going to make guessed
random, I'm going to use random dot random again.
And this time we're going between low and high.
Now we don't want it to always be between one
and x, right? Because we want to be able to kind
of change these bounds according to the user's
feedback, because you know that if something is
too high, then anything above that we can kind
of stop considering. And then if it's too low,
anything below that we can stop considering.
So that's why I'm passing in these low and high
values into this random so that we can get a new
number between the bounds that we know has to be
correct. Okay, so we have a guest. And now we're
trying to ask the user for feedback, hey, is our
guest right? Or is it wrong. So here, I'm going to
do feedback equals, and let's say user input is.
So I'm going to use an F string again. So
I can put this variable inside my string
is guess, too high. And let's make that Ah, okay,
too low, that's going to be L, or correct. And
that, of course, is C, the user is going to input
h, l, or C, I have these uppercase letters here,
this lowercase up here, I'm just going to make
this input lowercase. So adding that dot lower
at the end is going to take whatever this string
is from the input, and just lowercase it. So H,
L and C are all lowercase. If we try to compare
capitalized letter to its lowercase letter, it
actually does not come out to be equal. So that's
why I'm adding this lower in there. Let's look at
our different cases again. So if feedback is H,
so basically, we're saying okay, if it's too high,
then that means we want to adjust our upper bound
is a very guess, is too high. Like, you know, if
we're guessing out of 10, and we guess eight, the
other person says, Oh, that's too high, that means
out nine and 10 cannot be the numbers, that would
mean that we need to adjust our upper bound, our
upper bound is actually going to be what we just
guessed, minus one. Because for example, if we get
eight, then we know it's between one and seven
if eight is too high. And now if the feedback
is L, we know that our low bound has to be guess,
plus one, right? Because it can't be that low
number. And of course, we can make that an LS LS
makes it a little bit cleaner, because feedback
can only be h, or it can be L, like it can't be
both of them. And of course, if it's correct,
we don't have to have an if statement for that.
Because our while loop kind of takes care of that.
So at the very end, of course, when we
exit our while loop, that means that
the computer has guessed our number correctly.
Print, yay, the computer, guess your number.
Let's put the number in there correctly. And
so I'm going to put a guess, in this f string,
because so that means that outside of this
for loop, this variable guess is actually
the last thing that the computer had guessed.
Which means that you know, if it's correct,
then that is our secret number. All right. So
basically, one other thing that I've noticed
is random dot Rand and will actually throw
an error if low and high are the same number.
So we can do a couple of things, we could
theoretically put this statement up here that
prevents this loop from continuing if low equals
high, because if low and high are the same number,
that means that you've narrowed it down,
right? If you're saying eight is too low,
and your new low is nine, and then you're saying
10 is too high, so then your new highs nine,
well, that means that the computer has actually
narrowed down the number to nine. But if we break
too early, so if we're saying and low does not
equal high, then we don't actually iterate over
this loop. When our low is nine or higher is nine,
right? We just break and we say, Oh, the computer,
yes, your number correctly. But the thing is, we
actually want the user to say that the computer
has chosen it correctly. So that's why we can't
actually have that statement in there. Instead,
what we want is we want to say if low does not
equal high, then our guests is a random number
between low and high. Otherwise, so this means
if low does equal high, otherwise, our guests is
equal to one of them. So let's just say whoa, I
mean, it doesn't really matter. This could also
be high, because low is equal to high. Alright,
so then our feedback actually puts this number
into here and it prompts the user to say, hey,
that's, that's right. So then at the very end,
we're saying okay, the computer guessed your
number guess correctly. All right, let's try this.
file. Oh, shoot, and you can, let's say
our new secret number is six. So that's
too low. Seven. Oh, that's too high.
Six. Okay, that's correct. Yay.
And you know, we can even
play this with like 1000.
Alright, so for our secret number, let's actually
do the price of aetherium, which is approximately
392. Okay, so Python three main.pi 640, that's
too high to blow, too high, too low, too high.
Close, we're getting closer, oh 393, that's
a little bit too high, too low 392. What
the computer guess our number correctly, look
at that the computer has guessed our number
correctly. Alright, so that's it, just using some
functions and some while loops through, we're
actually able to get our computer to guess our
random number. And for us to be able to guess
our computer's random number. So now when we're
bored, we can play this guessing game. Whoo.
So the next beginner project idea is rock
paper scissors. This one's super simple,
but it's a step up from the previous one.
Here, we're going to be using random. So we
definitely want to import random, and we're
going to be using a function. So basically,
we want some user input, right, because
we want to play against the computer.
So the user is going to put an input, let's use
our for rock, p for paper, or s for scissors.
And then the computer is also going to choose. And
here we're going to do random choice because we
have our three different choices, our P and S. So
now the computer is going to randomly choose one
of these choices. Once we know the user's choice
and the computers choice, we can come up with some
rules in order to determine who wins. So the first
rule is if the user and the computer have both the
same choice, then it's a tie. In this game,
we know that rock beats scissors, scissors,
beats paper, and paper beats rock. So let's
define a helper function is when to see who wins.
And here I'm going to say player versus opponent.
And this will return true if the player wins.
And now we're just going to use
this little rule that we had.
See, so if the player is rock, and the
opponent is scissors, or if the player
is scissors, and the opponent, paper, or
so now we have three conditions, right?
Or the player is paper. And the opponent is rock
that we know that the player has won. So we're
going to return true. So now we're going to ask
up here if the user has one, so is when user or
computer so the computer is opponent and the user
is a player, then return you one, actually, we're
going to return, it's a tie up here. And then
otherwise, we're just going to return you lost,
because if the computer one that we lost, here,
you'll notice that I don't have an if statement
before this last return. And the reason for that
is because if you've already passed these two
cases, and after each of these cases, the function
ends right here, or in this case, if you one,
then it ends right here. The only way that we can
ever reach this line is if we didn't go through
any of these, which is the same, it just saves
you an extra line of code instead of saying else,
or instead of saying if is when computer comma
user, because the only way we get to this line
is if this is true, so we don't even need
that line. So here we're going to print play.
And here I'm actually going to add a
line break and say, what's your choice?
Now let's see what this looks like. What's your
choice are for Rock Paper Paper, Esther scissors.
Think I'm gonna go with scissors.
Oh, I lost play. Rock I won.
So the first thing that we have to do for hanging
man is we have to choose a random English word.
So I actually went on Stack Overflow, and I
found this very relevant question how to pick
a random English word from a list. And if you
scroll down a little bit, there's this like JSON
file that's linked. So I'm just going to click on
that. And when I open it, there's all of this text
And basically what this is, is it's just a very
long list of words that we can use for hang man.
So I can copy and paste this entire list of
English words into a Python file. And I can
assign it to the variable words, which we can use
in our hangman game later. So now I can open a
hang in file. And I know that I want to be able to
choose randomly from this word list. So I'm going
to import random. And then also, I know that I
want the word list that I just made. And I called
my file words that py. So in my hangman file, I'm
going to say from words, which is words.py import
words. And that second words is just this
variable words. So now if I print out words
in my hangman file, I would be able to get that
entire list of words that I just copy and pasted.
So the first step in actually getting
our computer to play Hey, man with us
is the computer has to figure out a word for us
to guess. So we just got this entire list of words
into this Python file. And now we just
have to randomly select a word from it.
But you'll notice if you look through this word
list that some of them actually have spaces,
and dashes in the middle of the word, which we
can't exactly guess in Python, or in hangman.
So we actually have to keep choosing a word until
we get a valid word that we can guess and hang in.
So in order to do that, I'm going to define
a function called get valid word. And I'm
going to pass it a list of words. So the first
thing I'm going to do is assign, you know the
word to random dot choice words. And what random
choices it takes in a list and it randomly chooses
something from that list. So I'm just going to
get a random word from this list. And I'm going to
make a while loop saying while dash or space is
in this word, keep choosing the word. So what this
while loop does is, as long as the statement is
true, it just keeps iterating back and forth until
it's not true anymore, which means that when
it stops iterating, we'll get a word that
doesn't have a space or a dash in it. And then
finally, we're just going to return that word,
we need to be able to keep track of which letters
we've guessed and which letters in the word we've
correctly guessed, we also need a way to keep
track of what is a valid letter, and what is
it. So now we're going to set that up, I'm going
to have word letters a variable that saves all
the letters in a word as a set. And this will
use as a way of keeping track of what's already
been guessed in the word. And then I'm going to
have an alphabet. And basically, I'm just going
to import this already predetermine list of like
uppercase characters in the English dictionary.
And then I'm going to have an empty set called
newsletters, which I will use in order to keep
track of what the user has guessed. Alright,
so now we're going to get some user input.
So basically, what we can do is we can just
ask for user input and Python directly.
And if we run this in Terminal, then the
user can type in, you know, a character.
And we can use that as input. So we're going
to save that as a letter. And I'm just going
to uppercase this because I'm just going to
do everything in uppercase. A lowercase a and
Python is different than an uppercase A. So if you
try to test equality between those two strings,
it actually won't be equal. So I'm just
going to do everything in uppercase.
And basically, if I'm going to, I'm
going to say, Okay, if this is already,
if this is a valid character in the alphabet
that I haven't used yet, that I'm going to
add this to my use letters set. And then, if
the letter that I just guessed is in the word,
then I'm going to remove that letter from word
letters. So every single time I guess correctly,
then this word letters, we're just keeping track
of all the letters in a word, decreases in size.
And then if this user letter that the user just
entered his and use letters, then that means
that they've already used it before, and it's
an invalid guess. So I'm just going to print
something saying, You literally just guessed that
word for that letter. Otherwise, that means that
you know, they typed in something that's not in
the alphabet, and it's not in the newsletters
that they've already guessed. So that just means
that they've typed it in a wrong character. And
we're going to print an error message saying
you didn't type in about Out character.
So now that we can get the user input, we want the
user to be able to keep guessing until they get
the word. So in this case, we're going to be using
a loop. And loops are basically just a way to,
you know, loop around your code and iterate. So,
in this specific case, I want to use a while loop,
because I want the user to just to keep
guessing until they actually guessed the word.
And because every single time we're removing a
letter from word letters, which is a set of the
letters in the word that we haven't seen yet,
I'm just going to keep decrementing that so
the condition that I have to satisfy for when the
user gets all the letters in the word is when the
length of word letters is actually equal to zero.
So while the length of word letters is greater
than zero, I'm going to keep iterating through
this input until they guess all the letters.
So my while condition is going to be while the
length of word letters is greater than zero,
iterate. So let's just add that in there.
So before we can actually play this game
of paying man, we need two things that we
need to tell the user. So the first thing is
what letters they've already used, so that they
can keep track of what they've already guessed.
So we're just going to have a simple print
statement. And then we're going to, say,
space dot join us letters. And what the start
join does is it turns this list into, or iterable,
into a string, separated by whatever the
string is before the dot join. So in this case,
each of these letters will be in
a string separated by a space.
The second thing that we need to do is we need
to tell the user what the current word is,
but with dashes where the characters that they
haven't guessed are. So in this case, I'm going to
first create a list where every single letter
that they've guessed, is shown, and where all
the letters that they haven't guessed, are just
dashes. And then I'm going to take that list. And
I'm going to join it with a space just like above
so that we can create a string using that list.
In that game, I literally could have
guessed as many times as I wanted to.
So let's make this a little bit more fun.
Let's introduce the concept of lives and to
hang and because usually and hang man, you
can only guess until the guy's dead, right.
So let's say that live, let's say you get six
lives. So the first thing we have to do is,
if the user has a letter in Word letters,
then you want to remove the letter.
But if they don't, then that's when you want to
take away a life. So with my logs variable, which
is set to six at the beginning, I'm just going to
subtract one there, and I'm going to tell the user
that your letter, user letter is not in the
word. And then everything else should stay
the same. Now at the very beginning, I'm going
to say where the, where I show the user the
letters that they've already used, I'm gonna, I'm
just going to tell them, you have x lives left.
And then you know, they can guess the letter.
And right now our while loop condition is set to
as long as they still have to guess more
letters in the word they keep playing. But
now we have another condition, right, we have
the condition of lives. So as long as either a
they haven't won yet, which is when the length
of the word letters is greater than zero, or B,
when they haven't died yet. So up here, we're
going to add another condition in this while loop,
we're going to say while the like the word letters
is greater than zero, and lives greater than zero,
then we want them to be able to guess this means
that as soon as they either when, when they,
when they've guess all the letters, then they
exit this while loop or when they've died when
lives equals zero, they exit this while loop. So
at the very end, right now we're telling them that
they've guessed the word correctly. But now that's
not the condition anymore for this while loop.
We also have an aspect of lives. So if
the lie equals zero, then they actually
died. So we say sorry, you died, the word was
blank. Otherwise, in this LC ms, we can say,
yeah, you guess the word. So now let's try again
paying man with all these different components.
Now we're going to create a command line version
of tic tac toe with various types of players. So
either a human can play, or the computer can play.
So humans can play as a computer, humans can play
against each other, or the computer can even play
against the computer. Let's get started, we're
going to split up our player and our game into two
separate classes. So that when we actually play,
we can create a game and then we can tell the
game, hey, this is my x player, and this is
my o player. So the first thing we're going to do
is create a file player.py. And up here, I'm just
going to tell you guys right away, we're probably
going to need math and random, so I'm just going
to import them right now. We're going to have a
bass player class and in this class, we're going
to initialize it with the letter that the player
is going to represent. And this is either x,
or Oh, so that's cross are not in official like to
Tac Toe terms. So self dot letter is going to be
letter. And we want all players to be able to get
their next move. So here, I'm going to say define,
get move, self comma game. And I'm just going to
pass because while this is our bass player class,
and on top of that, we're going to build a random
computer player. And we're going to build a human
player here, we're going to use inheritance in
order to create a random computer player and a
human computer player that builds on top of this
bass player object. And so in our initialization,
we have to initialize the superclass. So we're
going to say super dot init letter. And what
that's going to do is it's going to call this
initialization and the superclass, which is
the player and define get move. So in our
get move function, let's hold off on this for
now. Same thing for the human player. In this
human player, our superclass is still player,
we're going to initialize the same way that we did
the random computer player, and then we're going
to find get move, and again, self comma game. And
let's also come back to this, let's first go and
define the game to see exactly what we're dealing
with when we pass in the game. Let's create
another file. Let's call this one game.py. So in
game.pi, we're going to find class tic tac toe.
And so in this class, what are we going to need,
we're going to need a board, right? Because our
tic tac toe, it's a three by three board. Let's
create that board. For our board, let's just use
a list of length nine, that'll represent the
three by three board. And what we can do is we
can assign an index in this length nine list to
each of the spaces. And then that will represent
our board. What I'm also going to do is I'm
going to have this variable self current winner
that will keep track of whether or not there is
a current winner in this game. And if there is,
Who is it? Well, let's first of all be able to
print the board, right, we're going to want to
see like what's in this board. So for each row,
and here, let's split this up into the rows.
So self dot board, this is indexing into our
length nine list, and then this i times three.
So we're doing i in range three, right? So this
i times three to i plus one times three. So
basically that's saying like which group of three
spaces are we choosing? Is it the first one second
one or third one, and that that represents the
row indices 012. That's the first row indices 345.
That's the second row and then 678, that's the
third row. For each row. What we're going to do
is we're going to print and these are just going
to be some separators. So let's add these and then
dot join row is just saying like join them in a
string where the separator is this vertical line.
So you guys don't have to worry too much about
print board because I don't think it actually
like, contributes much to the logic of the game.
It's just how do you print this? Okay, and then
here for print board numbers, well, this is static
method because it's, it doesn't relate to any
specific board, we don't have to pass in a self.
What this means is, we're just going to print out
which numbers correspond to which spot. And so
for example, here, you can see it's 012, etc. And
so our number board is going to be string, and
then whatever is for each eye in range. Again,
this is a row, right? This number board might seem
kind of scary. But if we think about this for Jane
range three, so that's J equals 012. Here, this
range is j times three, and then j plus one times
three. So this is the exact same range that we
saw up here for each row. So what this is saying
is, essentially, just give me what indices
are in the rows for each of the rows, this
is going to come out to like 012, that's one sub
array, and then 345, that's another sub array, and
then 678, we're going to concatenate the strings
the same way that we did above in print board.
Okay, so now let's actually dig a little deeper
into the logic of the game. Given this board,
we're representing the empty spaces with
the space, we're going to need to know
what are the available moves
after you make a move, right,
so we're going to return a list and this is going
to be a list of indices. So let's actually expand
this out. And then I'm going to show you guys
how to do the list comprehension for it. Let's
initialize moves to an empty list. And then let's
say for icon x, and enumerate self dot board,
enumerate is going to essentially create a
list and assign tuples that have the index
comma the value at that index. So here we have
zero comma x, one comma x and then two comma Oh,
in the support loop, we're going
through each of these tuples.
And we're assigning the first item in the tuple to
I The second item to x. so we can say if x equals
Actually, let's call this spot, because that might
be a little bit more intuitive if spot equals
space. And we know that this is an empty space.
And we know this isn't available to move. So we're
going to append that index, because we want to
know which spaces are available, we're going to
append the index of that spot to moves. And they
at the end, we're going to return moves. Another
way to write this is a list comprehension. And
that would look something like this, I for icom
a spot in enumerate self dot board, if spot equals
space. So this is essentially just condensing this
entire for loop into a single line. It's saying
for icom a spot and in numerating, the board,
if the spot is space, then put AI into this list,
and then we're going to return the entire list.
Easy little one liner makes the code clean. Okay,
so now that we have that function, let's define
get move for our players. So the square that we're
going to choose for the random computer player,
while we're literally going to just choose
a random spot on the board that's empty.
So let's just do random dot choice, which
is going to choose one thing in a list at
random. And we're going to pass in game,
which is our board, game dot available
moves. Again, it's just going to get a random
valid spot. Okay, so the human player, we want
the human to be able to choose a spot based on
some input that we pass in through terminal,
we want the user to keep iterating until they
achieve a valid square. Initially, we're gonna
say valid square equals false. And then the value
is not because the user has an input value yet,
let's say while not valid square, so while valid
square is false, r square is going to be input
and then self dot letter. So x or o player
turn, because we want the user to actually
look at Terminal and not get confused by whose
turn it is. And input move zero through nine.
So what we're going to do is we're going to
incorporate a series of checks to make sure that
this is actually a valid number that we can put
in. So here we're going to wrap it in a trench.
So for the tribe, we're going to say
value. So this Val equals int of square,
remember square is this input that the user has
been put, if we can't cast this to an integer if
we can't cast this to a number, so if they input
like XYZ for square, it's going to raise an error
when you try to cast it to an integer and then
the second part If the value that they give you
is not in gamed out available moves in the list of
available moves, then we can raise a value error.
And so essentially, if either one of these
things goes wrong, then we know it's not valid,
right? If we pass both of those, and we can say
valid square equals true, because it's valid, then
we're going to catch this value error. And we're
going to say, print invalid square, try again.
And so this is going to repeat the loop, we're
going to get the input for the square again,
and we're going to repeat this checker. At the
very end, once we've gotten a valid square,
we're going to return that value at the end. So
it's going to be the human players. Next move.
Okay, so we have our player. So let's now
continue working on our game. So that we
can start playing a game of tic tac toe, we have
part of a representation of a tic tac toe board.
Let's, in order to get the rest of the
functions that we need, let's define a
function called play outside of this class, where
we're passing in a game, an X player, an O player,
and I'm going to pass in this extra variable print
game that's just going to be set to true or false.
And if it's true, it'll print out all the steps.
So this is like if you want to play against it.
But later on, if we want the computer to play
against itself, or like a bunch of iterations,
we don't need to see the computer print out every
single game. So then we can toggle that to false.
If we're printing the game, then we're gonna say
game dot print board numbers, right, because then
we can see which numbers correspond to which spot
and the starting letter, let's just assign that x.
I don't know if that's like, what two tackle
actually starts with, but we're just gonna say x.
Alright, so now while the game still has
empty squares, so while the game is still
like incomplete, we're just going to keep
iterating, right, and we don't have to worry
about the winner. Because the output of this
play, let's just return the winner, we don't
have to worry about continuing this loop, because
we'll break out of it with that return statement.
So in order to check whether the game still has
empty squares, let's create a function within the
class called empty squares, pass in self. And what
we're going to do is we're going to check if there
are any empty squares on the board. So we can
just say return space in self dot board. And space
and self dot board will become a Boolean, empty
squares will just return a Boolean of whether or
not there are empty spaces in the board. And we
might need to know the number of empty squares.
So I'm just gonna say okay, we can
return the length of available moves,
which will return this list. And so we
can just count how many empty spots there
are. We could also say self dot board count,
because this is a list, self dot board count,
and then just space. So that will count
the number of spaces in the board.
All right, so while they're empty squares,
we want to get the move from the appropriate
player. So if the letter equals O, then
we're going to ask the player to get move.
And if not, oh, that means it's x, then we're
going to ask the x player to get the move.
Alright, let's define a function
to actually make a move.
Now that we've gotten the player to get
their next move, we go back up to our game.
And we say define make move. When we make a
move, we need information about what square
the user wants their move to be at. And then
what letter the player is. So we know like
what to assign that square, if the move is valid,
then we make the move, and then we return true.
If it's not a valid move, then we return false.
Nothing should ever be an invalid move. But just
in case if self dot boards square is empty, so
if this This means if at that space on the board,
nothing's there yet, then we assign that letter
to that given square, and we return true. If
that doesn't pass, then we return false.
Okay, so let's put this into our play loop.
So if game dot make move, so if this is valid, if
we want to print the game, we're going to print
letter make some move to square, blank, and
some square let's make an F string there.
And we're gonna say game dot print board, because
we want to see a new representation of the board,
where this spot has now been claimed by this user.
And here, this is just an empty line that we're
going to print. Okay. After we made our move, we
need to alternate letters. So here we're going to
assign letter equal to O if the old letter was x,
otherwise we assigned it to x. And this basically
a different way to rewrite this would just be if
letter equals x, then the new letter is though
otherwise the newletter is x. That's exactly what
we're doing here. We're just switching players.
Okay, but wait, we don't, we're not actually
checking anywhere if anybody wants. So what if
we want, if you think about it, the only time that
you should win a game is like right after you make
a move, right? If you won, if you want a game, you
should win on that move. So we're going to go back
to make move. And after we've placed the letter
on that board, we can toggle current winner
to the winner if there is one. So let's make
another function that will check for the winner.
So after we've made this move, if self dot winner,
and then we're going to pass in our last move,
because that's the one that's going to be
our winning move, right? If self dot winner
then we can assign current winner equal to that
letter. Welcome back to The winner function. But
suppose that we have this checker. So then after
making this move, if we have a current winner,
we can check for the current winner before we
switch letters. And if there is a current winners,
which means, which means that if current winner
is not set to none anymore, then a letter has one,
and we can end the game because then we
can just return the winner of the game.
So in this game, we're going to
return the winner if there is one,
and if there isn't, then we're going to
return none. So that means none as a tie.
And we're going to return the letter of
the winner. So here if game current winner,
well, it was letter, turn, so we can just
return letter, the letter that gave us the win.
Okay, so then also, let's just add in the
non for a tie right now. So at the bottom,
we can say if print game, then after this while
loop is over, we can just print, it's a tie.
All right, now we got to go back and actually
create this function that'll check for a winner,
right? So we can define winner and
then input the square and the letter.
And we know that in tic tac toe, we're a
winner if there's three in a row, anywhere,
but we have to check all the possibilities,
whether that's in the row, column or the diagonal.
Alright, so first, let's check the row. So
the row index, which row it's at is going to
be whatever square that you give it, divided by
three, and then rounded down, right, so that's
what this right here is. So that double dash is
just saying how many times three go into square
row is going to be self dot board. And here we're
going to see this indexing again. But this is
essentially saying, given the row index, get the
row. So here rows is going to be a list of the
items in the row that we've selected. And we can
say, if all. So this is going to be all is saying
like if everything in this list is true, then
this comes out to true otherwise, it comes out
to false. So for all and then, within this list,
we're gonna do another list comprehension. So for
every spot on the row, we're checking whether or
not that spot equals the letter, because that's
how we're checking for three in a row. So if, and
then if all the things in this row are equal to
that letter, so that means that we have three
in a row in this row, then we can return true.
If not, then we keep going right. So then let's
check the column next. And we're going to use
very similar logic. So the column index is okay
divided by three and then take the leftover,
so that's going to tell us which column we were
in the columns is going to be the self dot board.
And here we're going to do another little indexing
trick. But if we take the column index, and then
for every single row, so
that's I, for every single row,
if we add the column index, and we essentially
get every single value in that column, right,
and we're going to put that in a list, and that's
going to be our column. So here column is just
going to get everything in the column where
we just move to. And again, just like above,
we're going to use this if all checker and instead
of row we're just going to replace it with column.
So if everything in the column is equal to the
letter, then we return true. Okay, so now finally,
if that doesn't come out to true, we're going to
check our diagonals. Intuitively, we can kind of
see that the only way to win a diagonal is if
you placed a move that was along a diagonal
here, we're going to check if the square that we
had just moved to is actually an even number 02468
These are the only moves possible because these
are the only these are the diagonal spaces.
So if we assigned 012 to the top row 345678, it's
pretty easy to see that the top left is zero,
the middle is four, and the bottom right is
eight. And then the other diagonal would be two,
four, and six. So that's why here we're
checking if the squares are visible by two.
So that that's basically saying it's even, then
this diagonal one, we're gonna say four is 048.
So this is the top left to bottom right diagonal.
So we're going to put the things in the board that
correspond to 04, and eight into this diagonal
one. And the same thing for diagonal two,
but instead, it's two, four, and six. So this
is the top right to the bottom, left, diagonal.
And once again, we're going to use this if
checker and say if every single spot equals
a letter in the diagonal, so diagonal one,
return true. And again, for this diagonal to,
if every single spot equals a letter in
diagonal two, we're going to return true.
And at the very end, if all these checks fail,
then we don't have a winner. So we return false.
So yeah, that's our Tic Tac Toe game right there.
And so now let's actually play this game. So if
name equals main, if name equals main, first,
we're going to make the x player equal to human
player and assign it the letter X. So actually,
at the very top, we have to go back and we have to
import human player and random computer player
from our player file. Otherwise, this game.py file
has no idea what's in player.pi. But if we add in
this like, import at the top, that we actually got
our human player, and we get our random computer
player. So for our x player, we're going to create
a human player, and we're gonna initialize
it with the letter x. And then our o player,
we're going to make that our random computer
player and assign that an O. And then our game
is going to be tic tac toe, let's just
call that T. And then we're going to say t
equals an instance of tic tac toe. And we're going
to play tic tac toe. So this is a game x player,
a player and then we're going to set
print game equal to true right here.
Alright, so let's pull up a terminal and
let's play a game. So Python three game.pi.
Alright, so first, I want to move to
four, because I want to be in the middle.
Okay, it's saying it's a tie. That's weird. But
oh, makes a move to square seven. Let's try to
go fix this. It's a tie. So if we go back
into our loop, we actually see that print,
it's a tie is still within this while loop.
And that's not right, what we need to do is
actually on indented to make it fall outside
the while loop. So it's only after there are
no more available spots, which means that there
is a tie Are we going to print, it's a tie.
First, we're going to go again, square four.
Oh is making a move to square five. Okay,
so I actually don't like how as
soon as I said, Okay, go to for
the computers like print out its move immediately.
So what I'm going to do is during this while loop,
so for every single iteration that we switch
on and off, I'm going to add in a tiny pause.
And I can do that by calling time dot sleep. And
let's just say 0.8, that's 0.8 seconds. And at the
very top, we have to import time in order to make
this work. So here, we're going to do a little
tiny break to make things a little bit easier
to read essentially. And let's try rings again.
So we make us move to square four. l makes a move
to square six. And let's try the top left. So
00 goes to three and we want
that bottom right. So let's do
908 we actually have to fix that text too, though.
Okay, so we see that we win though. Alright,
let's go back into the code.
And it should actually be
in a player dot pie here. We're just going to edit
this. It's actually zero to eight. Okay, save it.
So we were able to actually detect that it was
an invalid square and that we had to try again.
So yeah, that is our bare bones
Tic Tac Toe implementation.
Alright, so we created a game
of tic tac toe in Python.
And we created a human player and
we created a random computer player.
But can we do better? Can we make it so that
the computer literally never loses? Maybe ties,
but never loses? And the answer is yes. So
let's take a look at how we're going to do that.
minimax is a decision making algorithm built off
of a Maximizer and minimizer concept. Basically,
you're trying to maximize your win while your
opponent is trying to minimize their loss.
Now, in a game of tic tac toe, we can step through
each state, and see how minimax might help us win
and become victorious. In mini Max, we are trying
to find the best move to make, we can determine
this by trying out all the moves, and figuring
out which one is most optimal. There's something
called a utility function, which is basically a
measurement of how valuable the final result in
that tree is. Now let's take a look at an example
using a partially completed game of tic tac toe.
So in this current board, it's X's turn. And
obviously, the goal is to maximize x since we
want to win. So the first step is to put down
an X in every single possible potential move.
You'll notice that in the middle, we actually
won the game because we formed three in a row.
Now let's talk about this utility
function for a little bit.
Since we want to win, we want our utility to be
positive, since this is a positive value to us.
Now, in addition, I have this factor of three,
because I want to win in as little steps as
possible. So how I got this number is I took
the remaining squares on the board and added
one so that if you did win, you still ended up
with a positive value and not zero. And then I
multiplied it by either plus one or minus one,
depending on who the winner was. So for example,
if Oh had actually won in this situation, with two
squares left, then I would have done negative one,
times two plus one, three, which is negative
three. So moving on from there, we want to map
out all the possible scenarios of gameplay.
So continuing this tree, we have this layer,
and then this layer until the board is filled, or
until somebody has won. Now let's add the utility
function for all of these. Since Oh, one on
the left, we're going to do negative one,
times one plus one, since there's one
square left, which gives us negative two.
In the second one, nobody wins, and
it's a draw, so the value is just zero.
Now on the right, the first one, we went again,
but in this case, we don't have any empty squares.
So we're just going to multiply one by one.
And then on the right, on the far right,
it's a draw again, so we have a value of
zero. Now that we have these utility values,
we can propagate them back up to
find the most optimal path to take.
So at the very bottom level, we have a Maximizer
function, because it's X's turn, there's actually
no decision to be made in the bottom row,
because there's only one option one path to take.
In the second row, it's his turn, and we assume
that Oh, we'll be taking their most optimal path,
which means that we want to minimize the value
that o has. And in this case, on the left hand
side, it's between negative two and zero.
And since negative two is less than zero,
the left gets assign a value or utility value
of negative two, the middle is still three
because there's no additional options after
that. And on the far right, we're choosing
between one and zero. And since zero is less
than one, the far right has a utility of zero.
And the next stage, it's back to X's turn, and
we want to maximize x between negative two,
three and zero. Obviously three is a maximum,
so we would choose that middle path. So now we
know what the most optimal solution is in order
to win in the least number of steps possible.
Alright, so for our implementation, we are
going to create a genius computer player.
And this of course, is going to take
player as a superclass once again,
and here we're going to initialize it the
same way we initialize our other two players.
So in our unbeatable computer player, we also
want to get money. And get move is where all
the magic is gonna happen. At the very beginning,
if all the spaces are available, let's just say,
grab a random spot and just go there. So
we're just randomly going to choose one.
Otherwise. Alright, so now we're going to get
the square based off of the minimax algorithm
that we described. So because of the nature of the
algorithm and how it's recursive, we're going to
define a function minimax, outside of our get move
function, but we're going to call that from here.
So self dot minimax. And we're going to need to
pass in the game and the letter of the player. So
we know that we can win enough the other player.
So at the very end, we return the square that
was returned from our algorithm. And now let's
define the algorithm here. So define minimax,
and then self commerce date, comma, player.
So the reason why I wanted to call the state
and not game was because at every single
iteration of minimax, we pass in a representation,
a screenshot of the game in that state. So I'm
just calling it state, it's just a variable name,
you could call it s, you could call it game, you
call it whatever, I'm going to call it state,
because in my head, we're passing in states,
we're passing in screenshots of the game.
Alright, so the max player is going to
be yourself because you want to maximize
your score. So it's going to be self dot
letter. And then other player is going to be
other players. So whatever the letter is not. So
first, we want to check if the previous move is
opener. Alright, so when we have recursion, we
always need a base case. And this base case is,
well, at the very end of things. Where
are we at. So here, we want to see,
you know, was there a winner in any of the states
that we've passed in, so we know that in our game,
we have a current winner. So if the current
winner is equal to whatever other player is,
then we should return the position. And the score
these we need to keep track of both of these
things for the algorithm to work. So we're going
to turn this into a dictionary, so the position is
none. And the score well, so this is the formula
that I was talking about earlier, we're going to
multiply one times the State DOT number of empty
squares, because we want to maximize the number of
empty squares, we want to get to a win as soon as
possible. plus one, if the other player is the max
player, right? Otherwise, we're going to do the
exact same thing, but multiplied by negative one.
So LS negative one and then State
DOT number of empty squares,
and then plus one. Okay, so if there's no
winner, but if there are empty squares,
well, that means that nobody's won. So our score
is going to be neutral, it's going to be zero.
And the position again, will be none, because we
didn't move anywhere. Alright, so these are our
base cases. Alright, so now here, we're going to
get into the algorithm. So if the player is a max
player, then we're going to initialize a variable
best, and this is going to be a dictionary, that's
going to save the best position to move and the
best score. And because this player is going to
be the max player yourself, you want to maximize
that every single time step. So you're comparing
every single score to the score, and you're trying
to increment it. So that means that we want to
initialize it to the lowest possible score. So at
least one iteration will beat that score. If we
initialize it to negative infinity, anything
that's defined is going to beat that score.
If the player is not the max player, then we want
the position to still be initialized to none.
But the score we want to initialize infinity,
because we're trying to minimize at every single
point. So we're trying to decrease that. So we
have to initialize to like the highest possible
value. So for every single possible move in the
available moves, we're going to do a few things.
So the first step is we're going to make
a move, and we're going to try that spot.
So in step two, we're going to recurse using
many Mac's to simulate a game after making
that move. So what happens, like from there on
if we make that move? Alright, so step three,
we're going to have to undo that move so that
we can try the next one in a future iteration,
right. The fourth and final step is
we need to update the dictionaries,
if necessary. So if your score from that possible
move, actually beats the current best score,
then we want to replace that dictionary with
whatever we get from that possible move. Alright,
so let's get into implementing these. So for step
one, we want to call our State DOT make move,
and this is going to be whatever possible And the
player that's making that move. So player, right,
and then our simulated score is going to be, well,
we just made that move. So now we're going to pass
the new state into mini max again. And so here,
I'm going to call self dot mini max state comma,
and then we're going to alternate players.
So it's going to be the other player.
Step three, we undo the move. So at that possible
move on the board, we reset it to an empty space.
And then we set the state current winner back
to none. So this is undoing whatever move that
we just did, and the simulated score. Okay, so
remember that at the very end, we return this
position and then not right, so we actually
have to set what position we just moved to.
So here, our simulated score position actually
equals the possible move that we've just passed
in. Otherwise, this would kind of get messed up
from like the recursion part. Alright, so now in
our fourth and final step, we say if the player
is the max player, if the sim score is actually
greater than our best score, then we replace this
best dictionary with the sim score dictionary.
Otherwise, this means that your players
actually the mid player and your sim score,
if it's less than your best score, we again
replace our best dictionary with the same
score because we've successfully gotten a lower
score. And so what we're doing is we're trying to
maximize the max player, but minimize the
other player. And at the very, very end,
after we've tried every single possible step,
then our best score, this best dictionary
will contain the best next possible move, and
the best score that can arise from it right,
it ends up returning a dictionary of the position
and the score. So in order to use that in our get
move for our genius computer player,
we have to actually index for position,
and then that'll return the square the
position where we're actually going to go.
Oh, actually, this should be class. Sorry,
that was a little mistake from my end.
All right. And now instead
of random computer player,
let's try playing against the genius computer
player. And we have to of course, import that.
Let's start a game, we're going to go to the
middle square, so for and we get this air.
So let's go back to our code. And where do we
call that? Where does this air coming from?
So we actually said we're missing
an ASP right here. small mistake.
So let's try rewriting this after we fix
that. So four, they go to zero, let's go to
the bottom left looks pretty good. And that
is square six. So let's go to square six.
All right, they go to square two. So we
got a block, we got to go to square one,
they kind of forced our hand one. Alright, they go
to seven. So this, this is going to be a tie game,
right? So no matter where we go, I mean, yeah,
it's a tie. Right? Let's try again. And I'm going
to show you how this algorithm is actually going
to make a move cleverly, to a spot where, like,
it'll win. So it's, I'm just going to show
you, it's going to go there in the middle.
So let's go to the left and see what happens.
So that's where six, the algorithm knows,
to take that bottom spot to win. And here, what
we actually can do is, we can set this genius
computer player to play against a random computer
player. And what I'm going to do is actually
print turn print game to false. And make this
play a bunch of times. So we're gonna keep track
of number of x wins, oh wins, and ties. And then
we're gonna say like, let's run this 1000 times.
Remember that play passes back whoever wins,
right? Alright, so I'm actually going to put
this time dot sleep in print game, otherwise,
it's going to be kind of it's going to slow
it down unnecessarily. So at the very end, our
result is going to be whatever place that data
because that's the winner. So if the result
is x, then we're going to increment x wins
plus equals one. If the result is Oh, then
we're going to increment o wins by one.
And then now if it's none, so that means x doesn't
win or doesn't win the we're going to increment
ties by one and then at the very end, we're gonna
print like who won what, right so after 1000
iterations, we see x wins. x wins. We see oh wins.
Oh wins. And then we see ties number of ties.
Alright, let's try running this 1000 times.
This actually takes a while to run. So let's do
a little bit of magic called video editing. And
bam, we see that after 1000 iterations, we see
0x, one 793, a wins, and 207 ties. And you
can run this with the human with the random
computer player as x or Oh, but if you're
playing against a genius computer player,
you will realize that it never loses. It
only wins and it only ties but it never
loses. You can run this with like a
million iterations and it will not lose.
Before we implement binary search, let's actually
understand what binary search is binary search
algorithm is a divide and conquer algorithm,
which actually helps you search an ordered list
faster than just scanning every single element
and asking, Hey, is it Is this it? Is this it.
And what I mean by dividing conquer is that
binary search essentially works like this. So
assume that we have some list of ordered elements
from least to greatest. And we're trying to see
if this target is in the list, and if it is, then
return the index of where it is. So essentially,
we're searching this list for this target. So what
we can do in binary search is we can go to that
middle element of this list, and we can ask, Hey,
is the target equal less than or greater than this
middle element? If it's equal to then Well, we've
found it right. But if it's less than one, then we
know that it actually has to be on the left side
of that element. And we can completely disregard
searching anything greater than that element,
so we can completely disregard the right hand
side of that list. And now vice versa,
if it's greater than that middle element,
then we only have to search the right half
of the list. And now, again, we can reiterate
on that one section. So we divide and then we
conquer that one section. So in that left side,
let's say that our target is smaller than so let's
say Our target is seven, and seven is less than
15. So on that left hand side, what we can do
is we can redo the exact same thing, take the
middle of that left hand side, our target is less
than, greater than or equal to if it's equal to,
we're done, we found it. If it's less
than, again, we look at the left hand side,
if it's greater than that, we look at the right
hand side. But up to that middle point where we've
already checked these, we're limiting ourselves
to that left hand side of the array. Let's say
that our target is actually greater than this next
middle. And so then we look again on that right
hand side of the array. And you can imagine how,
with a really, really big array, we keep dividing
in half every single time, because eventually,
it'll either be the midpoint of a bigger array,
or we'll come down to like a sub array of like
size one. And then we found our element there.
So in this project, I'm actually going to prove
that binary search is faster than naive searching
by naive search, I just mean, you're iterating
through the entire list. And you're asking, Hey,
does this value cool our target? What about here,
here, here, here, here, and so on. And so you're
basically asking every single element
until you hit whatever your target is.
So now you've searched we're scanning the entire
list asking if it's equal to the target. If it is,
then we return the index. If not, then we return
negative one. So let's define naive search, we're
going to give it a list L and a target. So for
i in range, length l. So for every single index,
if l at that index is a target,
then we return that index.
Otherwise, we've gone through the entire
list, nothing's there, we return negative one.
For example, our l could be one 310
12, right? And if 10 is our target,
then we're saying okay, for the first
I, so if I will zero or element numbers,
one that does not equal the target, keep going.
So then three, the three equal target, no,
keep going. Alright, so now we're at index two.
Okay, well, 10 equals the target. So we return
to and if it's not in there, then we end
up returning negative one at the very end.
Okay, so then binary search uses again,
divide and conquer. So we will leverage
the fact that our list is sorted
in order to make our search faster.
So let's define binary search and then
give it again a list L and a target.
Alright, so here I'm going to provide
another example and I'm actually To add
one more element in here, so it's one longer
than our previous example. So 135 1012. And
let's say we're searching for 10. Again. And so
here, we're just saying, okay, it should return
three, index three, because 10 is at index
three. So the first thing that we have to
do is we have to find our midpoint. So our
midpoint is going to be the length of this list,
and then divided by two, but rounded down and this
double dash here, this means this means how many
times to go into length, right, so that's going to
give us approximately the index of the midpoint.
So now, if l at this midpoint, so this list
at the midpoint is equal to the target,
then we can return that midpoint
right there, because that's our index.
Now, if the target is less than the value at that
midpoint, so our targets 10, our values five,
so this is comparing 10, less than five, right?
Which is not true. But if it were, again, this is
saying like chop off half of the list, and iterate
over only one section of it. So we're going to
recurse. So we're going to use binary search
again, on that one section that we're given,
which here would be one comma three, if this value
if this statement had been true. So again, we're
gonna have to pass in some list, and I'm just
gonna leave this as l For now, we have to divide
it, we're not dividing anything right now. But
I'll get back to it. So then in the L statement,
well, this means that the target has to be
greater than whatever values at that midpoint,
so we only check what's to the right of it. Right.
So then we do another binary search. All right,
now these two, I told you guys, I would get back
to the fact that we're going to divide it in a
bit. And what we can do is, we could theoretically
say, okay, actually just pass in that half of the
array, so we could index L, so that it's the
left or right hand side, but then we just have
to add the index back in another way is that we
can add in low and high into our binary search,
and these are going to be the lowest indices
to the highest indices that we search.
And then here, when we recurse, we can say the low
is equal to the current low, but the new high is
going to be the midpoint minus one. And then for
the other side, we can say the low is now going to
be, well, the next one after the midpoint, all the
way until whatever the original high value was,
and again, low and higher indices. So these are
all the indices in our list that we can check. And
these are just bounds on the indices. Alright, so
first, if low is none, then let's set low to zero
because we want low to be the lowest possible
index that we can check. And then high if high
is none, high is going to be the highest possible
index that we can check, which is length L minus
one. All right, and then for our midpoint, instead
of just the length of L, we're going to change
this to low plus high because remember, this
is the lowest indicee plus the highest indicee.
So the average of those two would be whatever
index is in the middle. So that's our midpoint.
How do we know that our targets not even
in the list, what we can do is we can say,
All right down here every single time Our
target is to the left of the midpoint,
we're actually subtracting one from the high. And
then every single time Our target is to the right
of the midpoint, we're adding one to the midpoint
for the low. So if the high bound is ever less
than the low bound, that should never happen,
theoretically, if this were iterated properly,
the only time is when it can't find it, though the
target is not in the list, then we return negative
one. So that's our case of you know, it's it's
not in this list. Alright, so if name equals main,
then let's create a list 135 1012. Let's
make the target equal to 10. And then let's
print naive search of this list and then the
target. And then also binary search for that.
Alright, opening terminal. Let's run the script.
And we see both of them return three. All right,
now let's do a little bit of timing analysis to
show you guys that it actually works to not check
the entire list. Alright, so let's set legs to
10,000. And so here we're going to just build a
random sorted list of life 10,000. Let's say the
values in our sorted list, let's initialize it to
a set first. And then while the length of the set
is less than length, well, we're going to add some
random integer. And just to have bounds on this,
let's do something like negative three times the
length of the list and then all the way till three
times the length of the list. So that gives us
a range of like Negative 30,000 to 30,000 for
our algorithm to just choose a random
number and add it into this list.
Alright, so then after this is
done, then we're going to say,
okay, make the sorted list into a list, and
then sorted. So that's what sorted is. So and
then we're going to reassign this to the variable
sorted list. And then we're going to import time,
because well, we're gonna want to time
how long it takes for each of those.
And how we're gonna do that is we're gonna say,
okay, start equals time, that time, so that gets a
time right now. And then we're going to call naive
search on the sorted list, and get some target.
And let's actually say, let's iterate
through every single item in this list,
and try to find that item in the list. So
for target in the sorted list, so that means
we're going through the inherits word list
and making everything the target, and then
running naive search on that one target. So we're
basically running naive search 10,000 times here.
And the end time is going to be again
time dot time, at that spot. And so
then the knife search time is actually
just the end time minus the start time.
And so we can actually do this per
iteration if we divide it by length. So
for each iteration, on average, it's going to be
n minus start, and then divide that by length,
number of seconds. And again, we're gonna
do the exact same thing for binary search,
but make it binary search. So let's run that.
Okay, we see that naive search takes approximately
like point 443, like millisecond, so that's
443 microseconds, whereas binary search, I
mean, it takes 6.8 microseconds. So let's
compare that that's like 6.8, compared to 400,
something for a nice search. So yeah, basically,
if you ever have to search a sorted list, never
search every single item. I'm going to show you
guys how to build a command line version of
Minesweeper that looks something like this.
We're going to be using recursion and classes
to build our game. Now, before we get started,
I just want to say that I'm building a very
bare bones command line version of this game,
because I believe that when you're learning
how to code, if you actually want to learn how
to translate your ideas and algorithms into
Python, the bulk of that is going to be in
actually implementing the game, not figuring out
how the UI works. I think that the UI while it's
important, it is somewhat secondary, to actually
learning the coding process and the algorithmic
process that's involved with building these games.
Let's start off by defining the play function.
So here, our goal of this function is to play
the game. So we're going to find play pass in a
dimension size, which is going to be the size of
the board, and the number of bombs on the board.
Alright, so in step one, we're going to create
the board and plant the bonds. In step two,
we're going to show the user the board and ask
them where they want to go. And now step three,
well, if the location is a bomb, then we show
the game over message because they just dug
where there was a bomb and but if the location
is not a bomb, then we dig recursively until
each square is at least next to a bomb, right? So
you think about how Minesweeper works if you dig
somewhere, and it's empty, and everything around
it is empty, then you keep digging until you get
to a number and that number represents that that
square is next to a bomb. And then in step four,
we repeat steps two and three until there are
no more places to dig. And then we've achieved
victory. Alright, so right now we're just going to
say path because we'll get back to this function.
Okay, so let's take advantage of our
object oriented programming tools that
we have in Python. And let's create a board
object to represent the Minesweeper game.
So this is where we can say, create a new object,
or dig here, or render this game for this object.
Let's define a class called board. And here we're
going to initialize it with the dimension size,
and the number of boards. So let's keep track
of these parameters because they're going to
be helpful later on. So let's assign self doubt,
dimension, size, dim size to the dimension size
that was passed in. And then self dot number of
bombs to the number of bombs that will pass in.
And then we're going to create the board. But
let's get back to that. And at the very end,
we're going to initialize a set to keep track of
which locations we've uncovered which locations
we've dug in where the user has gone. So self dot
dog is going to be an empty set. Okay, and then
let's create the board. So let's actually use a
helper function. So self dot board equals self
dot make new boards. And here we're going
to plant the bombs to. So let's define that.
Alright, so we're going to find, make
new board, pass and self. And basically,
this is going to construct a new board based
on the dimension size and the number of bombs
that we pass in. And there are a bunch of
different representations that we can use,
that can be like a list of lists where each
sub list is just a row of this board. So here,
we're going to generate a new board, this board
is going to equal it's going to be none and
then repeat that dimension size number of times,
because that's how long we want this list to be.
And then we're going to have dimension size
number of these lists so that we can get
a square board. And so this creates an array that
looks something like this, it's just going to
be a board where it's non non non non non etc,
for whatever dimension size that we define it.
So then next, we have to plant the bonds. So here,
we're going to say bombs planted equals zero,
we're just going to use a while loop. And we can
say, while bonds planted is less than cell phone
number bombs, we can pick a random location
for the bomb, right, so let's actually go up
here and let's import random. And now for
the location, we're going to do random dot
Rand int, and somewhere between zero and CELTA
dimension, size squared minus one. So you can
think about this logic as like, we're literally
assigning a number from zero, you know, to the
number of spots on the board, and we're assigning
each spot on the board its own unique ID. And
then this random dot Rand n is returning a random
integer n, such a is between the bound A and B. So
a would be zero, B would be the largest ID in that
list. And then here, we want to actually get the
row and the column of that ID that we've chosen
from this random selector. So we're going to do
the location and then this double slash self
dot dem size. And what this is going to do,
it's going to say, how many times is my dimension
size, go into whatever location that I've chosen,
that's going to be the row that we're indexing in.
And then now, once we have the row, how do we know
which column we have to divide by the dimension
size, and then whatever index is leftover,
that's going to be how far into that list, we
have to index in order to find the column. So
once we have the row index and the column index,
we can index into the board. And then we can say,
if board and then row column, we're going to
index into that specific row column location
on the board, if it equals a bomb, so the stars
what we're going to use to represent the bombs,
then this means that we've actually planted
a bomb there already. So we're not going to
increase bombs planted, right? Instead, we're
just going to keep going. And this is actually
the reason why I'm using a while loop and not a
for loop. Because in a for loop, you know, every
single time we skip, we're like continue, we're
still counting that as an iteration. But here,
I only want to increment when I actually get
something that's not a bomb yet. And then I plant
the bomb. So yeah, that's why I'm using a counter.
And that's why I'm saying, hey, check it, this is
a bomb, if it is keep going. If not, then we're
actually going to plant the bomb. And then we're
going to increment this counter bombs planted. And
at the very end, I'm going to return the board.
Alright, so that is making our new board
we're going to plant the bombs right there.
Alright, so what other information is useful?
Well, we want to know, at each spot on this board,
how many bonds are around that spot that's going
to help us when we choose where to actually
dig right when the user input something, well, how
do we know where you know whether or not we should
keep digging around it? And yes, we can implement
a check at each point where we say like, oh,
if we did here, we're going to check all its
neighbors and we're going to dig again and,
you know, so on. But we can also just assign
values to every single space on the board that
represents How many bonds are in the neighboring
spaces. So let's call that assign values to board.
So here let's define assign
values to board and pass in self.
Alright, so now that we have the bombs planted,
we're assigning a number zero through eight
for all the empty spaces that don't have
bombs. And this is basically representing
how many neighboring bombs are
there, we can pre compute these,
and it'll save some effort checking what's
around that square later on. Basically,
we want to check every row and every column.
So for our end range, self dot dimension, size,
for C and range self that dimension size, this is
going to be the row index and the column index.
So if the item at the board, so if, at those
indices on the board, it's a bomb, we're going to
continue, right, because we don't want to actually
override any of the bombs that we've planted.
But if it's not, then we pass this if statement,
and then we say, okay, for this location on the
board, let's create a new function called get num
neighboring bonds, pass in the row index and the
column index. And then this function is going to
give us the number of bombs that is surrounding
that row, comma, column. Alright, so let's define
this define get number of neighboring bombs, we're
passing in the row and the column. Like if you're
confused of why I have our comma see up top,
and then row comma call, these are just variable
names, you just have to make sure that they match
where you're actually calling them. So
for example, when I call the function,
I'm passing it r comma C, because I've defined
R, and I've defined C in my for loop. So those
are variables that I've defined. And now
when I create this new function, I can
call the parameters that get passed in whatever I
want, right. And so here, the R would correspond
to the row and the C would correspond to the
column. So now let's iterate through each of the
neighboring positions and sum up the number of
bombs. So here, I've kind of imported a list
of all the neighboring positions, you can see
that top left is row minus one column minus one,
and middle is row minus one column, you know, and
so on. And so we're going to check all of these,
and we have to make sure that we don't go out
of bounds. So that's just a little reminder.
Okay, so first, we're going to initialize
the number of neighboring bombs. So just to
a variable set to zero, this
is going to be our counter.
And then we're gonna say for our in range row
minus one row plus one. And then keep in mind
that due to the nature of the range function in
Python, we have to add a plus one to the end.
And then same thing for the column for C and
range column minus one column, plus one plus one.
That should be plus. Alright, so basically, what
we're doing here is for the current row that we're
at, we're checking below and above. And then for
the current column, we're checking to the left and
to the right. And so when we sum up all these
combinations, we get every little piece of the
three by three grid. And then we can say, if
r equals the current row that we've passed in,
and if sequels called the column that we've
passed in, this is basically saying, like this
is our original location, we don't actually have
to check this. So we continue. But if it's not,
if self dot board at RC equal to star, so that
means that there is a bomb at that location,
that means that we have a neighboring bomb, right,
and so we can increment number of neighboring
bombs by one. And then at the very end, after
we've gone through all the neighbors, we're just
going to return the total number of neighboring
bombs. Now we have to go back up here and we have
to make sure that we don't actually go out of
bounds, right, because row What if rho is zero,
what if we're checking the first row row minus one
is going to be negative one that's out of balance.
Here, we're gonna add a max statement just to make
sure that you know row minus one, if it ever goes
past negative one, we're going to take zero every
single time we go below that zero bound. And then
for the upper bound, we're going to do the same
thing. We're in take the men of rho plus one, and
then self dot dimension size, minus one because
that is the maximum index that we can go, right.
And then of course, we're gonna use the exact
same logic for the columns, just like this.
solve some spacing stuff. And so yeah, now
we've got our bounds checking a we can return
the number of neighboring bonds. Alright,
let's go back to our play function now.
So step one is creating the board and planning
the bonds. So what we can do is we can say the
board equals an instance of this board
class, and then we're going to pass in
the dimension size. And the number of bombs
that we've passed into this play function.
And this is going to automatically, you know,
go through that initialization function. And
it's going to initialize the board and plant the
bombs and create an empty set for dog, and so on.
Alright, so now part two, we're going to show
the use of the board and ask where they want
to dig. And then we're gonna check if the
location is a bomb is not a bomb, we're going
to dig recursively. So let's actually go back
and let's implement some of these functions,
so that we have them, you know, handy when
we need them. So let's define a function
called dig within the board class. And we
can dig at a certain row and column index.
So we're digging at whatever
location the user has specified.
And let's return true if it's a successful dig.
And then a false. If we've actually dug a bomb,
it's game over and we've lost. So there are a few
scenarios here, right either, you know, we can dig
somewhere and we hit a bomb, and then it's game
over, we can dig out a location with neighboring
bombs. And then you know, we finish the day
because we've uncovered a number that's not zero.
But we might also be digging at a spot where
there are no neighboring bonds. And in that case,
we want to dig its neighbors until we actually
get somewhere where there are neighboring bombs.
So the first thing that we want to do when
we dig at a row, comma column, is we want
to add a tuple to self dot dug to make sure that
we're keeping track of where we've actually dug.
And then we're going to check the
board at that row and column. So
in our first scenario, if it's a bomb,
we return false if there's a bomb dog.
Now, if we check that space, and you know, it's a
number that's greater than zero, that means that
we've dug out a location with neighboring bombs.
And we finish the dig. So we just return true
because we did not take a bomb. So now if at that
row and column on the board, it's not a bomb,
it's not a number greater than zero, it
means that that spot is equal to zero,
right? So here, we're going to use the same
logic from get number of neighboring bombs,
where we're checking for the neighbors. And let's
paste that down here. So here, we're gonna check
R and C for all the neighbors. And so if r comma C
is in self dot dog, then we continue, because this
is basically saying, you know, don't dig where
you've already dug. That's pointless, right?
But after that, if it's not, then we dig at
that location. So we pass in our commissie
into this dig function again. And
we continue through all of this,
there shouldn't be a way where we ever get to a
bomb, right? Because we should always be stopping
at some square right before a bomb. So at
the very end, we're going to return true.
So I'm just going to add one more thing to this
Minesweeper game. This underscore underscore
string underscore, underscore. And so this is a
magic function, where if you call print on this
board, it's going to you know, it's going
to print out whatever the string function
returns. And so here, what we're going to want to
do is we're going to want to return a string that
shows a board to the player. And I'm going to go
over part of this function, but part of it was
kind of just like, like, if you inspect the code,
you'll be able to tell what we're kind of doing.
Okay, so first, we're going to create a new array
that represents what the user should see. So let's
call this visible board. So visible board is
going to be well, first, let's just create an
empty board, just as we did above, so that's going
to be our listing list. And it's going to be a sub
list of size, dimension size. And we're gonna
have dimension size number of those lists. So
now for every single row, and for every single
column, we're gonna use this for loop again.
If that row, comma column isn't self dot
dog, that means a user has dog at that spot.
So visible board at that row, and that column is
going to be whatever the actual board value is.
But if it's not dug already, then this is
actually just going to be a space because
the user shouldn't be able to see what's at
that location yet, they haven't dug there.
And we're going to put this entire board
representation in a string. Now what you
can do is you can just honestly return like a
string dot join, and then just this visible board.
In this code, I'm going to make it a little bit
cleaner. And this is all that this stuff here
is doing. It's just some formatting code.
You can look through it if you want, but
I'm just telling you right now, that it's just
completely formatting to make it look prettier
and to make it print out nice. And honestly, I
believe that knowing how to implement Minesweeper
is a lot more important to learn than learning how
to print out a representation of the game. Okay,
so now if we look at steps two, three, and four,
well, step four is basically repeating steps two,
and three, until there are no more places to dig.
So that kind of sounds like a while loop to me,
right. And here, what we're going
to do is we're going to say, well,
while the length of bore dug, so all the places
that you've dug, remember that this is a set,
so there are no duplicates, while the length of
the set is less than the board at dimension size,
squared, because that's how many spaces total
there are on the board minus number of bombs, then
we're gonna allow the user to play because it
means that they still have empty spaces on the
board where they can dig that are not bombs.
So the first thing we're going to do is we're
going to print the board. And we're gonna
ask the user, where would you like to dig?
And we're going to input this as row comma
call. So something like zero comma three.
And now, here, I'm going to use a regex split. So
that's what our e dot split is. It's saying input,
where would you like to dig, this is going to
return a string, and we're going to split that
string by this regex. And so this comma is
going to say, okay, detect any commas. And
then this parentheses slash slash s, well, this is
saying any whitespace, so any spaces that you see,
and the star at the end is going to say, zero
or more of those. So essentially, this is saying
match any part of this string that matches, you
know, just a comma, or a comma space, or a comma
space space, whatever the user types, we're going
to split that. So then we can handle something
like zero comma 00, comma space zero, or zero
comma spaces to space zero, right. And here we
have the import party. So let's go back to the top
and import our E so that we can split our string.
Okay, so now that we've split our input, we now
know what row and column the user is trying to
dig. So we can assign row and column to the user
input at zero and the user input at negative one.
The reason why we use negative one is sometimes
it's ru dot split has some fluff on the inside
of this list. And so if we know the row and
the column are at the beginning and the end,
then why not just take the first
and the last item in this list,
and I'm going to use it, because
we want these to be integers.
So now let's do some bounds checking if rho
is either less than zero or greater than board
dimension size, or if column is less than zero
greater than or equal to the dimension size,
we're out of bounds. So here, we're going to print
invalid location, try again. And we're going to
continue so that we repeat this loop over again,
until the user inputs A valid row and column.
But if the user did input something valid,
then we did get that location. So we can call
board dot dig at row, comma call. And so now we've
already implemented this part. So we don't have to
actually worry about the mechanisms of actually
digging. We know that war dot dig is going to
return true if we've dug successfully and false If
not, and so we can assign a variable called Safe,
whether or not our dig was safe. So whether
or not we've uncovered a bomb or not, right.
So at the very beginning, we're actually going to
say, safe is true, because at the very beginning,
we haven't done anything, you know,
we're safe, we have all of our lives.
And so, if not safe anymore, well, this means
that we've dunk a bomb. And that's bad. We're
gonna call break, because this means Game Over,
we shouldn't be continuing this loop anymore,
we shouldn't be allowing the user to dig. So we're
going to break out of that while loop. And now,
at the very end, there's two ways to exit this
while loop right? Either you've won and there's
no more spaces on the board where you can dig,
or you've dug a bomb. Nothing safe anymore.
And yeah, rip. So let's check which one.
If we're still safe, this means that we've
just run out of spaces today, we've dug
every single possible spot to dig. And so
we've actually won let's print. Congratulations,
you are victorious. Alright, but on the other
hand, if we're not safe, that means that we've
dug a bomb, and we can print. Sorry, game over.
and here we can actually reveal the whole board.
So we're gonna assign board dog to every single
possible value of our commissie on this board.
So this double for loop in this list
comprehension here is just saying,
take every single possible r comma c value of
this board and put it in this list, the very end,
we're going to print the board. And so this
is going to reveal every single possible spot.
Now let's call the play function
to actually play the game.
And we're going to put this in a name equals main
if statement, because this is just good practice.
It's basically saying like if you have a massive
project, but you only want to run this file,
the stuff underneath name equals main will only
run if you type in Python, three minesweeper.pi.
If you have a bunch of imports from bunch
of other files, it's not going to run any
of the code under name equals main in those files,
you're only running what's under name equals main
in that one file. Alright, so let's play the game.
First, let's stay get, I don't know 00. So here,
you see that we've dug at 00. It was zero. So that
means that you know, there were no bombs nearby.
And so we kept digging until you know, there
were some bombs nearby. So for our next spot,
let's just do four comma six. And then let's try
that bottom right corner. So nine, comma nine.
And you'll see that this actually dug a lot. So it
recursively dug everything that you see that zero,
it dug until it hits some spot that was
not zero. And if we look at this spot,
right here, three comma seven. Well, this
is actually, you know, very clearly a bomb,
right? So let's dig there on purpose. So we get
through seven, and it says sorry, game over.
And it actually reveals that yes, this was a
bomb. And this was the entire map of our game
to begin with. There you have it, a
command line version of Minesweeper.
next project is a Sudoku solver. In this tutorial,
you'll be able to see how we can use recursion to
solve any valid Sudoku puzzle. Okay, so the first
thing that we want to do is we want to define our
function solve Sudoku, and we want to pass in
our puzzle. Basically, this function is going
to solve Sudoku using a backtracking technique.
So our puzzle that we pass in is a list of lists
where each enter list is actually a row in the
Sudoku puzzle. So basically, this represents the
nine by nine puzzle. And we're turning whether
or not the solution exists. But in this code,
remember how lists are mutable. So we're actually
mutating this puzzle to be the solution if the
solution exists. So the first step is I'm actually
going to see where on the puzzle I can go. So as a
human, when we're playing Sudoku, we typically
go from where we have the most information,
whether it's the column that's most filled out,
or the row or the little tiny three by three box.
But because we have a computer, we don't have
to do that, what we can do is we can assign a
number to any open space on the board. And then
we can try essentially every single combination,
as long as it's valid. And when we see that it's
not valid, we can actually go back and say, oh,
let's not try three. Let's try four instead.
And if you think about the entire puzzle,
you can essentially come up with
like, every single combination, oh,
it doesn't work from there. Okay, well,
let's take a step back and try all the
combinations there. If none of those
work, then we take another step back,
and try all the combinations there, and so on. And
our computers actually powerful enough to do that.
So that's the technique that we're going to use
here. So our first step is actually to choose
somewhere on the board. To make a guess, in order
to do this, I'm going to create a helper function
called Find Next empty and pass in the puzzle.
So I can find the open spaces on the board.
So here, I'm going to define Find Next
empty passing puzzle. And essentially,
this function is going to find the next row
column on the puzzle that's not filled yet. And
in our puzzle, we're representing any open spaces
with negative one. So we basically want to return
the next space, that equals negative one. So we're
going to return the index of the row. So that's
if this is a list of lists, the first index that
we return is the location in that first list
that are empty spaces that the second value
that we're returning is within that row,
which index is it app. And then of course,
there might be a situation where our entire
board is filled, and there's no empty spaces left.
In that case, we're going to return a tuple non
common none. So keep in mind that we're actually
zero indexing. So we're starting from zero
and our last index is eight. So essentially, what
I can do is I can just go in order, I can say,
hey, check each row and then check each column.
And whatever the first empty space, you get I'm
just going to return the row comma column value of
that. So here I can do for each row in range nine,
so I'm iterating through my nine rows. And then
I can say for that row for each column value
in range nine, so that's my zero through eight.
If the puzzle and then here's how we index,
we pick out the row. And then within that row, we
use C to index again and get the column. So here,
this double indexing basically is returning the
item in the arthro and the C's column. And then
if that equals negative one, then basically
return that Farsi. Otherwise, we return
non common none. If we've iterated through this
entire puzzle, and nothing equals negative one,
then that means that there's no spaces in the
puzzle left, so we can return non common none.
Okay, so then the second step from there is,
well, if there's no word left, we're going to
be implementing some validation checks of like
whether our guests is actually valid or not. And
so if we filled out this entire puzzle, then that
means we're actually done. So here, I'm gonna say
if rho is none, so remember that above, we return
non common none. And then that first none gets
assigned to grow, the second none gets assigned
to call, and so we only have to check one of them.
Now, if row is none, then we can return true
because we've actually solved our puzzle.
But if we haven't, then we can keep
going. Alright, step two, is basically
if there's a place to put our guests, then
we want to come up with a guest between one
and nine. And we want to actually try all of
them until we find a combination that works.
So I'm going to say for gas in range one comma 10.
We start the next step, step three,
which is checking if this is a valid gas.
Okay, so here I'm going to use
another helper function is valid.
And I'm going to pass in the puzzle, guess,
row and column because those, those are the
key pieces of information that we need. In
order to determine whether or not this guess
at this row and column is valid in our puzzle.
So those are the four parameters that we need.
And here I'm going to define the function
is valid. And this basically figures out
whether the guess at that row or column of the
puzzle is valid. And so if there's no conflicts,
then we consider it valid. And then we
return true. We returned false if it's not.
So now we have to follow Sudoku rules. If our
guests equals anything that exists in that row,
or the column already, or even the little three by
three matrix that it's in, then it's not valid. So
let's actually start with the row because that was
the easy one, right? Every single list within our
puzzle represents a row. So if we have the row
index, then we can just say that the row values
are equal to the puzzle index at the row. So if
our guess is in row values, then we can return
false. All right, now the columns, the columns
are a little bit trickier because we actually vary
which row we're indexing into, but we index at the
same spot within each row. So what we can do is we
can create a new list called column values. And
we can say, for each row, I can say for iron rage
nine, so that will go through all the rows, I'm
going to append the value at puzzle at the I throw
at the call column. And so another way to write
this actually is using a list comprehension. Ryan
say take puzzle and then index into I and then
within that row index into call, and then do that
for i in range nine. And then that's essentially
going to build the exact same list. So then,
if the guess is in those values, then we return
false because it means that it's in our column.
And then now this little three by three square
matrix. So this parts a little bit trickier,
because we actually have to figure out where in
the three by three grid we are. And so to do this,
what we're going to do is we're going to find the
starting index of the row of that three by three
matrix, and then we're going to find the starting
column index of that three by three matrix.
And then we're going to say for each row
for each of the columns within that three,
we're going to iterate. So what we can do in
order to find this is actually take the row
index and divide it by three, but throw away the
remainder. What is like, for example, if I have
one divided by three, that comes out 2.333. So the
base, or whatever you want to call it is zero. And
then five divided by three, well, the remainder
is two, but three goes into five one time.
So I'm going to return one. So that I can take
that and I can figure out if it's in the first
set of three rows, the second set of three
rows, or the third set of three rows. And
then of course, in order to get like the actual
index of that, I have to multiply that value by
three. And then it's the exact same logic
for the columns. So when I get row start,
I'm trying to get the start value of these chunks,
right. But then when I'm getting the column,
I'm getting the start value of these chunks,
maybe it's the other way around on YouTube.
When I have both of the starts, I can
say, Hey, now we're going to iterate
through this. So I can say for our end range,
row, start comma, row start plus three, because
we want to iterate through the three rows for C
and range call start to call start plus three,
because we want to iterate through three columns,
if the value of the puzzle equals our guess,
so that means our guess is already in this three
by three matrix. So we just have to return false.
And now at the very end, if we've passed all these
checks that we haven't returned false yet, that
means that while it is valid, and we can return
true. Alright, so let's close those functions.
Okay, now back to our code. So if is valid is
true, then we want to actually place that guess,
on the puzzle at that row, comma column. So what
we can do is we can say puzzle index at the row
index at the column is now equal to our guests.
So we're actually mutating this puzzle array.
So now in step four, we're going
to recursively call our function.
Because if I guess one number, then that number
is actually mutated in my list of lists. And I
can pass that in as my puzzle. And then the
next value becomes mutated, and then so on,
until we reach the very end. So that's
essentially what we're doing here.
We're just solving this entire thing with this new
guests in our array. So if that comes out as true,
then we know that we've actually solved
our Sudoku puzzle so we can return true.
But of course, there's also the case where,
where this is valid check might not be valid.
And there's also this case of well, what if we
didn't solve the Sudoku when we pride that guests
in the row and column. So then, in this case,
we actually need to backtrack, we need to say,
hey, so this guess was wrong. Let's reset it and
move on to the next guess. So here, I'm going to
say puzzle row call equals negative one, because
we didn't successfully place anything there.
So we're essentially just resetting the value at
this row and column. And now you can imagine this
for loop is going to go over, you know, all the
possible values 123456789 for every single empty
spot along this entire puzzle, right. So that
means we're literally trying every single possible
combination for the Sudoku. So in our last step,
if we've tried every single combination possible,
and none of them work, then that means
that we actually can't find a solution.
So this puzzle is unsolvable. And
then we're going to return false.
Alright, so let's actually test this to prove that
it works. Okay. So Python three sudoku.pi, we see
that it comes out as true. And this is our board.
So let's try resizing this to see if we can like,
actually view this as a board. Okay,
there we go. Let's do a couple of checks,
just to make sure that like, our solution is
actually true. So in this first box up here,
let's do 123456789. Alright, and then this column,
you have 123456789 in this row, 123456789. Okay,
so that's pretty convincing that like, this
is actually a good solution. Okay, so a couple
of notes about my implementation. recursion is
confusing recursion kind of makes your brain hurt.
I think it might be better understood this
way. Think about solve Sudoku as a black box,
it should be able to mutate the input puzzle,
so that it's a solution if it's a valid input
puzzle. Now, if it's not a valid input puzzle,
well, then it should be able to identify that
because we've tried every single combination
for that puzzle. So when we make a new guess
we can pass This new guests as a puzzle into
our solve Sudoku function. And if it's solvable,
then we know that our guests was the correct
guests. And we've actually reached a solution.
Now, if it's not solvable, well, then we know that
that guests that we passed in, it's not a solvable
Sudoku solution. So we can say, okay, that wasn't
the right guess. So now let's move on to the next
one. And this is how we kind of go through this
entire puzzle, and mutate the Sudoku array that
we originally passed in to be the correct answer.
I hope that clears things up for you guys.
This next project is going to deal with editing
images in Python, I've prepared some starter code,
if you go to this link down below the one that's
for pi Photoshop, you can click this download
code, you can either download the zip file, or you
can get clone it if you know how to do that. And
let's take a look at what's in this code. So here
I've prepared for you a lake and a city image. And
so we're going to actually be editing these images
and doing like, cool things on those using Python.
So in the png.py file, this is some code
that Johan Rochelle put together. And I just
copy and pasted this from online. Essentially,
what it is, is it's a PNG reader and a writer.
And what that means is while the writer is a PNG
encoder in Python, and then the reader is a PNG
decoder in Python. So it takes a PNG image, and
it decodes it into like a Python array. And vice
versa. For the writer, it takes a Python array,
and it writes it to a PNG file. Pretty cool.
Alright, so now in this image class, this is some
code that I've prepared for you. And we can see in
this initialization, you can either initialize
it with x pixels, y pixels and num channels.
And that will initialize to an empty array
of zeros. Or you can import a file and this
image will represent whatever file that you've
imported. So here we have the input path and
the output path. These are just the folders
for the inputs and the outputs. And here we
have a checker to see if the user is actually
passing x pixels, y pixels, and num channels.
So if it has, we assign those values, and then
we create an empty array essentially, by the way,
number of channels just means like, for example,
typically, when we work with images, we work with
RGB channels, so that's red, green, and blue. And
so that's three channels. That's what we're going
to be using today. And then x pixels and y pixels
will describe the size, the actual physical size
of the image. So here, we're initializing
these to all zero. And this is going to be
a NumPy array of the size, x pixels, y pixels,
num channels. So you can think of this command as
kind of just creating a three dimensional matrix
with dimensions x pixels, y pixels, num channels,
and it's initialized to all zero. That's
essentially what self dot array is initialized to
when you pass in x pixels, wide pixels and
num channels. So if there is a file name,
then we actually read that image from this helper
function, read image and set that to the array.
And then x pixels, y pixels and num channels will
set to that array dot shape. At the very end,
we're going to add this elf statement. Because if
the user hasn't passed in X, Y and num channels,
or if they haven't passed in file name, then we're
actually going to raise a value error saying you
have to input one of those options. Okay, so let's
go over the read image function. So read image,
you have to pass in a filename. And this gamma,
you don't have to worry too much about that. It's
just a way to encode and decode it so that your
operations are not exactly linear. And so here,
I'm using PNG reader, this is from the PNG
file, and I'm passing in the file name, I'm
going to read it as a float. And then here, we're
just going to do a bunch of like resizing things.
I mean, I've given you guys these functions for
a reason. It's because I don't think that they're
critical in understanding how the actual photo
manipulation works. So then in this right image,
so this function call will write
whatever this image represents
to a PNG file, and we're clipping it to between
zero and one. The reason for that is because
when we transform it back into the alpha file,
we're going to scale everything from zero to 255.
And so we're going to do a little bit of reshaping
and write it out to the output file using the PNG
writer. And we're going to resize this array
because we did a little bit of Free shaping,
but we want to keep it in the same representation,
right, we don't want to actually mutate our
representation of the array. So down here, we're
just going to do a quick test to see that this,
like import and export works. So we're going
to call image equals image dot file name. And
let's use the lake. And all we're going to do
is we're going to right to the output file,
we're going to right image test dot png. And
what we should see is that test dot png should
be identical to Lake dot png, because we haven't
manipulated the array at all. So let's try that.
Okay, so test dot png, this is the same image. And
so where the bulk of our code is going to be is in
this transform.py file, we're going to implement a
couple of things here, the first thing that we're
going to implement is adjust brightness.
So how do we adjust the brightness here?
Basically, when we adjust the brightness, we
want to scale each value of the pixel by some
amount. factor that's a value greater than zero is
basically how would you want to brighten or darken
the image by if the factor is less than one, then
we're darkening. And if it's greater than one,
then we're brightening. So first, we have
to figure out how big exactly this image is,
so that we can iterate through each pixel. And so
first, we get image dot array dot shape, because
remember that we've stored our values
in self dot array for that image.
Alright, so basically, we're getting the x y
pixels, and then we're getting the channels. Okay,
and then basically, we're going to make
an empty image so that we don't actually
mutate this one that we're passing in. So this
new image is going to be x pixels equals x pixels,
y pixels equals y pixels. And then num channels
equals num channels. So it's going to be the exact
same size of the array that we pass in. But now
we're just going to be mutating this new image,
so that we don't change the original one. This
is maybe the most intuitive way to do this,
it's non vectorize. If you don't know what that
means, don't worry about it, I'll show you in a
bit. But essentially, we're going to iterate for
every single pixel and x pixels for every single
y pixel. And then for every single value of the
channel. So literally, you can imagine this 3d
matrix and you're iterating through each
individual value. And then for that value,
well, we have to adjust the brightness
by some factor. So we're going to say
new image. And we're going to take the array,
and then we're going to index into whatever
position that we're currently at. So x, y c. So
at index x, y c, we're going to set this equal
to our original image that array at
x, y, z, so that corresponding pixel
and then multiply that by the factor that
the user has input. And then at the very end,
we're just going to return the new image. So let's
actually try this first, see that it works. Here
at the very bottom, I've provided already a little
bit of code that tells you, alright, load the lake
and load the city. So let's lighten the lake
for example. So let's say Brian m equals adjust
brightness lake and then some factor greater
than one. So let's just do 1.7. And then we're
going to write this image to brightened dot png.
So let's try that. So Python three transform.pi,
and we get this image that's slightly brighter,
we can compare this to the lake. If we move
these side by side, you'll notice that
the brain one is like slightly brighter.
So let's actually try also
darkening so dark and image equals
adjust brightness. And then let's make the
factor 0.3. And let's save this as darkened.
And now running that again. Right, we get the
darkened image here. So we can tell that this
is darkened from our original image. And
let's compare these side by side again.
Right so the darkened image does look darker.
Okay, so I mentioned earlier that this is a non
vectorized way to do it. And this is because
this is the most intuitive like this is behind
the scenes if you are brightening or darkening
something you have to adjust every single
pixel value and increase or decrease it.
Alright, so one faster way to do it. Is the
vectorized version. So we said before that these
are NumPy arrays, but the strength of this such
array is that, okay, it's NumPy. But I've always
read it as not B. But basically, the strength
of this array is that you can vectorize these
operations. So if you want to add a constant,
if you want to multiply by some scaling factor,
you can directly just call that array, and then
times that factor, it's significantly faster than
iterating through using a for loop. And we can
see that this does the exact same thing if we
just let it run on the darkened image. So let's
do dark in image two. Let's call the Transform.
Alright, we get this darker image two. And this
looks the exact same as our darkened image.
Let's move on. Okay, we're going to adjust the
contrast now. So when we adjust the contrast,
we're going to be doing the same thing where we
want to create a new image copies so that we can
put new values in without modifying the original
image. We're going to be repeating this for x,
y, and z thing because even if you can vectorize
things, I like this way of just showing you guys
what's actually going on. Here, we're going
to index at x, y, z, that position again in
the array of the new image. So what adjust
contrast does is it adjust the contrast
by increasing the difference from the user defined
midpoint by some amount, factor. So essentially,
if your point is above the factor, then you
take that difference, you scale it by factor,
and then you add back whatever the midpoint was.
Same thing for the other side. So basically,
what you're doing is given this midpoint,
you're making the difference from the midpoint
greater. So we're going to take the image
array, and we're going to take the value at
x comma y comma z, subtract out the midpoint,
and then scale that by the factor factor.
And then we're going to add the midpoint back in.
Alright, and then of course, we return that
new image. And just to show you guys what the
vectorized version would look like, it's just new
image dot array equals the image dot array minus
mid, which is a constant. So it's taking that
entire array, subtracting this made from every
single value in that array, scaling that entire
array by factor, and then adding back a constant
mid. So it's literally taking every single item
in that array and adding the midpoint back in.
Alright, so now let's try adjusting the contrast
of this like image. So let's do increase contrast
equals adjust contrast Lake two, because remember,
the the higher the scaling is, the more contrast
we have, right. And let's do the mid points 0.5,
because we're working on a scale of zero to one
for these images. And now we're going to write the
image, let's call it increase contrast that PNG.
And I'm going to do the same thing,
but let's decrease the contrast now.
So I'm just going to do the same
thing except instead of two,
I'm going to pass in scaling factor 0.5.
And here, let's just call this decrease
contrast. And we're going to write this to
decreased contrast dot png. Let's run this.
Okay, so let's compare these. So this is our
original, and then this is a decreased contrast.
So you can see that it's significantly grayer.
And this gray just means that the contrast has
decreased. And everything's closer to being the
same color, which just happens to be great. And
now this is the increased contrast, you can tell
that like, I mean, the contrast has really been
increased, the colors are a lot more drastic in
this one, right. Okay, so the next thing that
we're going to implement is a blur for the image.
So in the blur, we pass in a kernel size. And this
kernel size just means how wide Do you want this
blur to be? Because essentially, what we're doing
when we're blurring is we're taking that pixel and
averaging it with its surrounding pixels. And so
if the kernel size is for example three, then that
just means we're taking a pixel and we're applying
this kernel around it, so it should be taking the
left and the right neighbors and top and bottom,
the four diagonal corners. For example, a kernel
size of 15 would take the seven to the left,
the seven to the right, and the seven to the
top and bottom and everything in that square.
Alright, so once again, we are going to create
a new image to make a copy to and We're just
going to use a naive implementation of iterating
through each neighbor and then taking the average
at the end, there is a faster way to do it. But
this again is more straightforward to understand,
it's more straightforward to figure out what
we're doing, the faster way to do it would be
to incorporate some sort of, like memorization,
which means so for example, what we would do is we
would move like along the x axis, and every single
time instead of resetting every single neighbor,
we just get rid of one column, and then we add
in the next column, and so on. And that would
decrease the number of operations that we actually
need. But, again, this is more straightforward. So
we're going to use this way for now. First, we're
going to create a variable total equals zero. And
this is going to keep track of what the total of
all the summations of the surrounding pixels are.
And, of course, we need to know how many neighbors
we actually have to go for. So we're going to find
neighbor range as how many times does to
go into the kernel. So how many neighbors
to one side do we need to look at
essentially, is what this represents.
And here, we're going to say, for each exci in
the range, x minus neighbour range to x plus
neighbor range. And remember that we
have to add this plus one, because range
goes from the lowest to the highest minus
one, right? That's just how Python works.
It doesn't include the end of the range. So you
may think that this is all good to go. But what if
x minus a neighbor range is actually less than
zero, then it would go out of bounds. So here,
we're going to add a little bit of bounds
checking. So we're gonna say take the max
of x minus neighbor range, or zero. So for
example, if x minus a range is negative,
then we would say, okay, no, cut it off at
zero. And same thing for x plus neighbor range,
we want this to be the minimum of the maximum
value that we can take, which would be x pixels
minus one. And the reason why we do minus
one is because x pixels is the length right,
and we have to subtract the one because that's the
highest possible value that we can actually index
into. Remember that Python, we do zero indexing.
So then again, we're going to do the same thing
for the Y neighbors. And we're going to
keep these bounds because they are the same,
but instead of x pixels, we do y pixels. And then
we do y plus the neighbor range, every single time
we go through a new neighbor, we want to add
that value from the past an image to our total.
And then at the very end, we can say our new
image at that specific index is equal to the total
and then divided by the total size of the
kernel. So how many things did you just sum over,
we have essentially a box of size nine, right
nine elements in that box. So we have to square
our curl size, and then divide our
total by that. And so that just gives
us the average value over that pixel at its
neighbors. And then we return this new image.
Okay, so I'm actually going to run
this blur on the city because the city,
it has more lines in it, it's
more obvious if it's blurred.
So let's do a blur with size three, blur
three equals blur city, comma three,
and then we're going to write image and call it
blur k three. And now I'm going to do the same
thing with a kernel size of 15. Just so that
I can show you guys the difference between
using a kernel size three, four blur, and using
a kernel size 15 for a blur. So let's run that.
Okay, so our blur of three is done. And
you can see that it looks slightly blurred.
When you compare it to the original, so our
blur, we know that our blur is doing the job,
and it's still running for the 15. Again,
this is not the fastest way to do it.
And the higher your kernel sizes, the slower
the more this is going to make a difference.
It looks like our 15 is now done. Okay, so let's
open that. And now we see that this is like
noticeably much more blurred than our original.
And the reason is literally just because we've
taken more pixels into account when we've
created this average for that one new pixel spot.
Okay, so actually this blur
that we've implemented above,
we've actually implemented
applying a kernel to an image.
And so what that means is we're taking a matrix
and we're applying it to every single pixel, and
summing up whatever values in that matrix times
whatever value is at the corresponding pixel.
So in this blur above, it's a kernel of size n by
n. And each value is actually one over n squared.
All right, let's see how we can create a function
apply kernel. So we can take in any kernel,
and we can apply it to our image. So we're going
to assume that the kernel is square, first thing
that we're going to do is we are going to, again,
paste the code that we had above. And here, our
kernel size is slightly different, because we're
not passing that in. Instead, we have a 2d NumPy
NumPy, 2d NumPy array that represents a kernel
that will use the kernel size is just one
dimension of the kernel 2d array. So we can just
say kernel dot shape, zero, we're going to keep
this iteration through the neighbor range. And
so here, we need to actually find what value of
the kernel corresponds to that pixel that we're
at. So x k is actually whatever exci we're at,
which is representing you know, x
minus that neighbor range, right?
So we're actually going to add that neighbor
range back in and subtract x. And you'll see
that what this does, is essentially, it's
centered around x y, right? So at x, y,
that would be the center of the entire kernel. But
now we're trying to shift the zero, for example,
up to the top left corner. So that's, that's that
those are the operations that we're doing here.
If you draw it out, it makes a lot more sense.
All right, and then for why we're doing by I,
plus a neighbor range, and then subtracting y from
it. Okay, so then the value at the kernel would be
Colonel and then index at x k, and YK. And
we add to our total, this variable total,
we add the image at that index x i y, I see. But
then we multiply it by the kernel value from our
kernel. And so then the new image, that array
is x, y, z, and that is equal to whatever the
sum of all of these are. And then of course,
we're going to return the new image. So let us
so I'm going to, so I'm going to show this
to you guys, on an edge detection kernel.
It's called the sobelle. kernel. So in the
x direction, it's going to be this array
121000, negative one, negative two, negative one,
and this y kernel will be the same, except there
will be some values or switch. So I can write this
in a 3d format that's a little bit easier to see.
And so we're applying this over every single
pixel in our image. And now here's the y's.
Alright, so you see, these are almost the same
thing, right? Let's apply this kernel to the city.
So let's call that civil x apply kernel city.
And then so we'll x kernel. And then we're
going to write this to edge x dot png, we're
going to do the exact same thing for the Y
kernel. And now you'll see why I called
these x and y. So let's run this.
We go here, and we look at the city on
one side. And now let's look at this
edge x. So you can see that this edge x
really like I mean, look at that horizontal
line right there. It's an X edge detection
filter. And now let's take a look at edge y.
So you can see how this one really highlights
the Y edges, right, the edges in the y direction.
It would be really cool if we could just put
these together and create an edge detection
filter. And that's exactly what we're going to do.
Next, we're going to combine these make an edge
detection filter for our image. So here, we're
going to combine images, image one and image two.
So one thing here is the size of image one and the
size of image two have to be the exact same thing,
the arrays have to be the exact same
dimensions. And we're going to again,
copy this shape and create a new image. And
we don't need any of that kernel stuff. But
basically what we're going to do is we're going
to take the value from image one, square it
the value from image to square it, add these two
together and then take the square root of the sum.
We have x y and C and index at the new image
is going to be it's going to be whatever is at
that index in image one squared plus whatever
is at that index and image two squared and then
the entire quantity, square root it So this to
the power of one half is just square root. And
at the end, we're going to return a new image.
And up here we are getting an error because this
should actually be a image one or image two, it
doesn't matter, they should be the same shape,
right? We said that, like when we
defined the function, let's try it on
sobelle, x and y. So uncomment some of this
stuff. And at the very end, we're going to do
soble x, y equals combine images, so about
x, and Sobell y. And so then symbol x y
dot right image, and let's call this edge
x, y dot png already. So let's run this.
So let's set all of these next to each other.
So on the bottom right, we have the original
image, then we have the x and the y filters. And
now check this out. So this is the images combined
the filters combined. And you can see that this
is a pretty cool edge detection filter. And let me
try to actually like zoom in, make this a bigger
image. So this is our image. And check that out.
I mean, you see all the edges in the image,
basically. Pretty cool. Look at that skyline.
And so yeah, using all of these
techniques, you could literally
implement Photoshop, in Python. Pretty cool.
So the last project I have
for you guys is what I call
graph composer. And it's kind of like an
introduction to AI. The idea of graph composer
is derived from a Markov chain. And so in a Markov
chain, you have a node that represents a value,
and it has an arrow pointing to maybe
another node that represents another value.
And that one might be pointing to another
node, which might point back to the first one,
and so on. So you kind of create this entire
network of nodes and directed edges with weights.
In our graph composer, what we're going to do
is we're going to take the text file, and we're
going to transform every single word in that text
file to a node, and then we're going to connect it
to whatever words follow that specific word. So
here's a little snippet about how these Markov
chain graph models actually work. Given a text,
I can generate a graph from the text where all
of the words are represented by vertices, and then
there's a directed edge from each word to the word
that follows in the text. Now the weight of the
edge would just be the number of times that the
new word follows the word that you just connected
it to. So let's take an example sentence,
how about I am subscribed to y cubed, and I
am loving it. so here we can take the letter I
and we can make it a vertex. And now we can
connect an edge with wait one 2am because an
follows I one time so far, and then subscribed, we
are connecting subscribe to an with the directed
edge of wait one, two, y cubed. And Okay, so
now things get a little bit interesting because
after this last, and it goes back to I, we already
have a vertex representing the word eye on our
graph. And so and is going to connect directly
to that vertex that's already in the graph,
okay, but then we have another occurrence of I
Am. So instead of creating another vertex for AM,
we're going to increase the value the
weight of that edge that's currently
there. So instead of one, we're turning
that into two, and then we can continue on
so am is already connected to subscribed. But now
loving also follows AM. So we're going to create a
new vertex for the word loving and assign that
a new edge with weight one, and then of course
it and now it gets connected to loving. So this
would be the graph that represents the sentence.
I am subscribed to y cube, and I am loving it. So
with all the songs of an artist that I've chosen,
I have basically created this like huge graph of
all the words as vertices and edges connecting
them to the words that follow. Okay, so now in
order to generate my poetry, I can randomly choose
a starting word by randomly choosing a starting
vertex, and then I can traverse the graph based
on the edges. So these edges are kind of rules for
which word you can go to next you can only follow
the arrows So here's an example. What I mean
by that, let's take the graph that we just saw.
And let's say that our starting word is y. So
I've got y, there's only one arrow out and to
cube. So my generating is going to be y cubed. And
because and is the only word that follows cubed.
And then of course, I because is the only thing
that follows. And, and then Am I right. So y
cubed, and I am well, now we have two arrows
out of and we have an arrow to subscribe, and
an arrow to loving, we can actually choose either
of these paths. And in my script, I've left that
up to randomness. So that's where these weights
come into play these edge weights come into play,
the higher weighted an edge is, the more likely
that path will get chosen. And this is how I can
generate these sentences all stitched together,
I'm going to show you guys how to actually
implement this in Python. First thing that we're
going to do is we're going to go to this code
that I've already prepared for you. What you can
do here is you can download the code over here,
you can download the zip file, or if you know how
to get clone. Go ahead and do that. Let's take a
look at what's actually in these files. Here. I
have two empty files compose up hi and graph.py.
Under songs I have, well I have a bunch of text
files that represent song lyrics. And we'll get
to those a little bit later. But basically,
we can generate lyrics using our little Markov
chain model. I also have under texts, this
Harry Potter Sorcerer's Stone text file,
and so we'll be able to see how we can actually
generate some text based off of Harry Potter as
well. And in lyrics.py, you guys don't really
have to worry about this. This is just a scraper
that, you know, you input some songs and then the
artists name and it'll scrape lyrics genius. For
those lyrics. Basically, it'll download this exe
and save it in the files that you guys saw before.
So graph.pi and compose up higher fd, because
while those are the things that I'm going to
show you guys how to implement. Let's start with
graph.pi. Also, guys, just letting you know that
in this tutorial, I will make mistakes. I wanted
to show you guys this because I wanted to let you
know that it is very, very normal to have bugs
in your code. It's very normal to make mistakes.
And the important part is to actually know
how to fix them. So just keep that in mind
while you're watching this tutorial. Okay, so in
graph dot pie, this is where we're actually going
to have our Markov chain representation. And,
you know, we know that in this Markov chain,
we're probably going to need randomness. So let's
import random right, now, we're going to define
the graph in terms of vertices, naturally, let's
create a class called vertex. First thing that
we're going to do, we're going to initialize
it, so define a knit, and we pass in a value.
Now this value is going to represent our word
from the text here, we can set self dot value
equals value. So whatever the vertex value is,
that's just going to be the value, that's going
to be the word that it represents. And here, I'm
going to have a dictionary called adjacent. And
what this adjacent dictionary is going to do, it's
going to keep track of you know which vertices
are connected to this vertex. And so those are
going to be our keys. And then the value of that
node is going to be our weight, the weight of the
edge from our current vertex to the adjacent one,
let's create a function called add edge
to. And so we have to pass in a vertex,
because we need to know which vertex we're drawing
the edge to. And let's create a weight of zero,
we can allow the user to manipulate the
weight, so let's pass in the weight.
But you know, we can set it to zero initially,
just in case you don't want to pass it anything
right, what we're going to do is we're going
to put this vertex in the adjacent dictionary,
and the value is again going to be the weight.
So this is all we have to do. Every single time
we're parsing our text, whenever we see a word,
go to another word that's already in its adjacent,
what we want to do is we want to increment that
edge, right? So here, we pass in the vertex. And
then we can say self, adjacent and vertex equals
self dot adjacent, get vertex, comma zeros. And
so this doc yet is just saying, if this vertex
is a key that's currently in self dot adjacent,
we're going to get the value of that vertex.
If it's if it doesn't exist, then we're just
going to default make it zero, and then we add
one. And so this add edge two is basically adding
an edge to the vertex that we're inputting with
some weight. Whereas this increment edge, we're
incrementing, the weight of the edge from
our current vertex to whatever vertex that we
give it. Alright, now that we have a bit of our
vertex representation, we can put this together
in a graph. So let's create another class called
graph. And we're going to of course initialize
this and we're just going to initialize this to
an empty dictionary. Have vertices. And the reason
why we do that is so that whenever we encounter a
new word, we can look it up in this dictionary and
then get the vertex object from this dictionary.
So this is going to be a string to vertex mapping.
Alright, so let's define a
function get vertex values.
And this is basically saying like what are the
values of all the vertices. In other words,
let's just return all the possible words that we
have in the graph. So what we can do is we can
return the set of self dot vertices, keys, and
this is just going to return all the words that
we've encountered so far. And then we can create a
function to add a vertex into our graph. So like,
for example, whenever we encounter a new word, we
want to add a vertex. So when we create a vertex,
we of course have to pass in a value, that's going
to be the word that it represents. We're going to
do self dot vertices value, equal old vertex of
that value. So we create a new vertex object. And
we're putting it in this string to vertex mapping.
And of course, we want to define get vertex,
because sometimes we'll just have a word and we
want to get the vertex object that it represents.
So if we pass in the text, the word value,
Well, okay, we want to return self dot vertices,
and then whatever is that that value, right,
because in this dictionary, we're mapping it to
the vertex and returning that object. But what if
the value isn't actually in the graph. So in that
case, what we want to do is we want to actually
add it in because if we're asking get vertex of
that value, well, it doesn't hurt to ever add
it. So if the value is not in self dot vertices,
we're going to add, we're going to
call self dot add vertex, that value,
we're just going to create
a new vertex for that value.
And then of course, return it afterwards. And the
most powerful part of this Markov chain is that
when you're at a node, you can say, Okay, get next
word, but based on these weight mappings, here,
we can create a function called get next word,
and pass in the current vertex. And what it's
going to do, it's going to first find whatever
vertex object corresponds to that current vertex.
So we can say self dot vertices, and
then the current vertex dot value.
And now let's create a function called Next
word, under this first text object. And what
we're going to do is we're going to randomly
select a Next word, but based on weights.
Alright, so if we actually go to look at the
random documentation, we see that there is this
function called random dot choices where
you pass in a list, give it some weights,
and it will actually choose randomly, but based on
the weights, so we're going to use that idea here.
Let's return random dot choices and pass in self.
Okay, but then how do we know what do we even pass
in? Right? Let's introduce this concept of
a probability map, we're going to map each
word to its probability, but put them in separate
lists. Alright, in this function for each vertex,
comma weight, and self dot adjacent dot
items, remember that self dot adjacent
is a dictionary that has each vertex and
then maps it to the corresponding weight.
Let's create two new lists to keep track of
the neighbors, and then the neighbor weights.
And so here, for every single vertex,
comma weight, what we're going to do is
we're going to append the vertex to self dot
neighbors. But we're gonna append the weight
to self dot neighbor weights. And so then we
can easily pass these into random dot choices.
So here, we can do random dot choices, self
dot neighbors, self dot neighbor weights.
All right, we actually see that random dot choices
returns a list. So we'll have to index and get
you know, there's it's a list of size one, but
we still have to get the first item in the list.
So we have to index zero. Now we can get our
next word. But where are we generating these
probability maps. Under graph, we can create a
function called generate probability mappings.
That'll get all the probability mappings of
every single vertex. Here, we're going to say,
for every vertex in self dot vertices dot values.
Well, what we're going to do is we're going to
call that vertex and we're going to say, Hey,
get the probability map. And so then as soon
as we call that function, every single vertex
will be initialized with the probability map.
And that is our graph representation. So now let's
move over to compose that pie. Let's think about
what we actually need to do here. Well, we need to
get the words from the text right and we need to
create a graph where the values of the vertices in
that Graph are those words. And then for X number
of words that's defined by the user, we need to
get the next word. And then we'll just show those
results to the user. So let's put all of these
inside a main function. Let's start with step one,
getting the word from the text, we can create a
function called get word from text, very original,
and pass in the path to whatever text that we're
trying to get the words from, we can use this
command with open text path, comm R. R stands for
read as F. Well, we can read everything in that
text, if we call F dot read and assign that to a
variable text. So this is going to be a string.
And now what we want to do is we kind of
want to split across all the whitespace
and then join it with one single whitespace.
So what this is going to do is like,
if there's like multiple lines, like, you
know, indents, whatever, it just creates, like,
it gets rid of all those and
replaces it with the single space.
So text, that split is going to split all of that,
you know, whitespace, whatever it is, tabs,
spaces, enters and replace it with a space.
So for example, text that looks like this would
become text that looks like this with only spaces.
Right? And then what we're going to do
is we're going to lowercase everything,
because it's easier to compare everything
when it's lowercase. And then now,
let's not try to deal with punctuation because
stuff can get a little bit complex, right?
There are cases where you might want to add
a period, but it's not actually the end of
the sentence might be an abbreviation. Like, for
example, Mr. Brightside, but Mr is not actually
the end of the sentence. So what we're going to
do here is we're just going to remove all the
punctuation. And we can do that by calling string
dot make trans that's make translation string,
we can import string, that's the Python package,
string dot punctuation is just going to be you
know, any of the punctuation that you can see in a
string. And what we're going to do is replace that
with empty strings. So here's something like,
Hello, it's me might become Hello, it's me.
And then, of course, we want to split all
the words. And we're going to do that by just
splitting on spaces again. So we can call text dot
split, then we're just going to return the list of
words. So return words. So under step one, we can
say words equals, get words from text, and then
pass in the path to for example, let's use Harry
Potter. So text slash HP Sorcerer's Stone, that's
the name of the text file dot txt. That's step one
right there. Now the next thing we want to do is
make a graph using those words. So let's define
a function, make graph and pass in the words.
Here, we have to import the graph and
the vertex from this graph.pi file.
So up here from graph, import graph, comma vertex,
and then G, let's assign this to a new graph.
And for each word, in words, we're going to check
that the word is in the graph. And if it's not,
then we add it. And so when we're going through
this word list, if we come across a new word,
then we want to check the previous word, if it
exists, which it should unless you're like the
very first word in the full paragraph. So if
there was a previous word, then we add an edge
if it didn't already exist in the graph.
Otherwise, we increment the weight of the
existing edge by one. And then we set our
word to the previous word, and we iterate.
So now remember that like, in order to get
the next word, we have to set the probability
mappings. And so this is a great place to do
it right before we return the graph object
in our make graph function. So let's start
in this implementation. For word in words,
we're going to check that the word is in the
graph. And if not, then we're going to add it.
So let's drag graph.pi over here, so
we can look at both simultaneously.
Okay, so you'll see that in get vertex, we
actually add the vertex already. So all we
need to do is we can say word vertex equals graph
dot get vertex and then that word, if there was a
previous word, then we add an edge if it doesn't
exist in the graph, otherwise, increment the
weight by one. So here let's actually create
a previous word variable and assign it to non
because at the very beginning, there is a previous
word. Here we're going to check the previous word
then previous word dot increment edge, word.
vertex, right, because what this is going to do,
it's going to increment that edge between
the previous word and the word vertex by one.
And here the increment edge already does
that for you. Because we've implemented
that in our vertex already. Now here, all
we have to do a set previous word equal to
whatever this word is. So that in our next
iteration, we have access to the previous word.
And we keep doing that for all words. And at the
very end, we can say g dot generate probability
mappings generate all the probability mappings
and then return that graph. Alright, so step two,
G equals make graph. And then we pass in the
words that we got from get words from text.
Now step three, we want to get the next word
for X number of words as defined by the user.
Let's create a function compose, given a
graph and given the words and some length,
let's just say 50. For now, we're going to
create a composition. And this is at first
going to be an empty list every single time that
we generate a new word, we're just going to put
it into this list composition. And what we can
say is that we'll look we have the words list,
let's just get some random word from this words
list. And, you know, grab that vertex from G. And
this is where we're starting. So for however
many iterations in the length that the user
has defined, we're just going to iterate and
we're going to keep getting the next word right
here, we can say composition dot append, and
then this word, which is the word vertex,
we're going to append the value of that vertex,
because remember, we can't actually append
the vertex and have that legible, we have to
append what word that vertex corresponds to.
And then now our next word is going to be g
dot get next word, given the current word.
So here, we can say word
equals g dot get next word,
and word. And what we're going to do is replace
this word variable and keep getting the next one.
At the very end, we're just
going to return our composition.
Right. Now down here in our main function,
again, we can say our composition equals compose,
we can pass in G, we can pass in words. And
then we can pass in some parameter length
override that we can say 100. for the heck
of it, we don't want to just return a list,
let's actually return a string. So we can join
this list of words by a space. And so this is
going to return a string where all the words
and composition are just separated by a space.
So now let's run this function and generate.
Okay, and because we're returning this
competition, we're not printing it.
Let's print whatever Maine returns. And
that's how we're going to see our composition.
Alrighty, so first, we can try running. And look
at that random is not defined. I forgot to define
that. So I go back up here, and I'm going to
import random. Save that and run it again.
Alright, so now, none type has no attribute
value. So this means that this word, dot value,
word is somehow none. So how in the world do we
fix that? To let's go back into our graph code.
And take a look at what's going on. It could
be g doc at vertex or G dot get next word,
one of those is probably returning
none. So let's open graph.pi.
And if we look at, get next word, okay, here,
we're calling Next word, but Oh, look, we're
never actually returning a value. And so that's
our bug. Let's add a return statement there.
And let's try running this again. And there we
go. It worked. Let's read this. This is built
off of our Harry Potter text. Do you are
some interesting so unfair that strangers?
They were going to let her to squeeze
him? I want to look at it had one who
has always Maroon tailcoats orange eyes away.
Just hope of his last look back to her. Anyone
else is very well, no answer. Professor Clairol
had been a bundle of white a Clearfield Harry Ron.
Alright, so this is kind of cool. But clearly
this, you know, it's some gibberish. And the
reason for that is just because our implementation
of simply a Markov chain is not very intelligent,
right? We're kind of just randomly choosing given
this word Pick a next word. One way that we could
make it better and more slightly like English,
is instead of saying like, hate this word,
maybe choose like the previous like three words,
right and then pick the next word based off of the
previous three words, and so on just so that it
has some sort of memory, so it doesn't jump around
as much. But now, maybe you're interested in Can
we do this with the songs that I have in here,
and I'm going to show you exactly how to
implement that. We can edit a couple of things,
but keep most of the logic the same. If we go
into like one, I'm Billy Eilish song, for example,
you'll see that we have this like chorus verse
thing in brackets. And that's obviously not like
part of the song. So we're going to remove like
the bracket and the text inside of it. We can
do that with a regex again. So what we're going
to do is we're going to say, hey, substitute,
and then this funky expression, which I'm going
to explain just a bit, but substitute that with
a space anywhere in the text, it's saying this
is a left bracket, this is a right bracket,
and here, this dot plus, so the dot means any
character, and plus means one or more. So this
means if there's one or more characters inside
the brackets, then replace any version of that
with the space in the text. And so here,
in order to use this, we have to import
our UI. And let's reformat some of this stuff,
okay. And so the rest of this should be the same,
because we still want to get rid of whitespace,
we still want to get rid of punctuation.
But instead of just, you know, one file name,
we actually have multiple, right in this folder.
And one way that we can like just have Python
read that folder, rather than having to type out
every single file name. If we import LS, and we
go down here, we can actually walk through this
folder and find all the file names within
that folder. So let's do that right here.
Okay, so for song file, in here, we're going to
use Oh s dot list, Dir. So that's list directory,
songs, and then we're gonna pass in an artist
name. Okay, so here, we're gonna use f string,
passing the artist. And then in Maine,
we're gonna pass in the artist. So what
this is going to do is, if you pass in this artist
name to align with that file name, for example,
Billy underscore Eilish, then, we're going to
list every single file that's under that folder.
And here, you know, for Green Day, you have
all these for Linkin Park, you have all these,
and so on. Alright, so after I get all the song
files, I can now call get word from text and pass
in this path songs, dash artists dash,
and then whatever the song file is.
So here, I'm going to put that in here song file.
So this is just going to get every single
song file and like, go through and get the
words from that. And up here, I'm going
to define words equals an empty list.
And then every single time we get a song's
words, we're just going to add that to the words
list. So we can extend by whatever
song words is. And so now down here,
we want to input the artist. So let's
input Taylor Swift. Let's try running this.
Okay, so we're getting an error. And usually I
would just Google this error. Honestly, this isn't
one that I'm super familiar with. Let's actually
print what the song files are. So we can figure
out which one it failed at. And so here, if we run
this, we actually see that it failed at this file
called dot d s store. And so this is just some
cash that's stored under this directory. It's not
actually a song file itself. And so we can just
say, like, if this equals dot d s store, then
continue because we're just going to keep going
the loop. And so if we run composer.pi again,
look, there's our Taylor Swift masterpiece.
I remember thinking, are we in red, because
they're you breathless, huh? Or it's time you need
to calm down. You're sorry for it used to hit you,
again, even if it's such a chance to paper
airplanes flying flying, and I've never
looked back together, who, etc. Again, this
is kind of gibberish. We could make it more
intelligent. But for now, as a beginner project,
this is pretty cool. you're generating paragraphs
based off of some vocabulary that you're
inputting through songs. or Harry Potter, etc.
If you enjoy this video be sure to subscribe to
my channel follow me on instagram and twitter
at Kylie y Yang if you guys are interested in
live coding sessions, where you know they're not
pre planned like these tutorials, you should
definitely follow me on Twitch. Kylie Yang.
Alright, hope to see you guys around. I hope you
guys enjoyed my videos. And yeah see you later